Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, liebe. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Irgendwelche Verschwörungstheorien, die neu dazugekommen sind, den du dich vielleicht anschließen möchtest.
Das kann ich ja jetzt öffentlich nicht sagen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik, zwei hoch sieben ein gefeiertes, binäres äh Jubiläum.
Ja und hier die Metaebene ist dekoriert.
Ja, früher war mehr Lametta, aber.
Ja, das ist schon in Ordnung hier, also was zwei Monitore zur,
um also die zwei der zwei zu huldigen.
Wohliges der zwei wird hier laufend gehuldigt.
Hundertachtundzwanzig Gigabyte, SSDs hier in den Geräten.
Das mit diesen ganzen,
näheren Potenzen noch nicht so entwickelt, wie man das immer gerne möchte. Naja,
wir arbeiten dran. Na ja, also wir haben auf jeden Fall keine besondere Feier äh vorbereitet.
Ja, ich weiß, die Hörer sitzen natürlich jetzt alle so mit äh Tröte und Partyhütchen direkt vorm Rechner. Ähm klar dem können wir dann auch einfach zuwinken so, ne. Hier habt ihr ein bisschen Kamelle,
Ansonsten ist ja jetzt nicht, gibt's ja jetzt nicht so viel zu feiern. Oder?
Ich finde das ein bisschen äh also ich finde das ein bisschen verletzend von dir, wie du das jetzt runterspielst.
Ich will jetzt die Erwartungen ein bisschen, weiß nicht, auf irgendwelche Dezimalgeburtstage eher schieben.
Ja ja und wenn wir Dezimalgeburtstage haben, dann ja, die binäre Geburtstage,
Linus, die Hexgeburtstage, die Hexgeburtstage, die zählen.
Aber wenn Note am Mann ist, dann können wir ja auch noch das Oktalsystem ausgraben. Geht ja immer irgendwas.
Als jedes Mal ein anderes Zahlensystem um um das Jubiläum klar.
Die Welt ist komplex und man muss flexibel reagieren können. Das ist äh auch das Thema der Woche, ja, also auch unsere,
sind ja mit äh neuen, alten Ideen,
darüber werden wir dann äh auch gleich noch reden, nichts sonderlich Überraschendes, nur irgendwie in der Art und Weise, wie sie da gebracht werden, immer wieder schockierend,
So oder so äh haben wir ja nun gerade auch eine Live-Sendung abgeliefert und jetzt haben wir es auch geschafft, äh die Videoaufzeichnung davon ins Netz zu bekommen, nachdem das Wok dann mal so die letzten Festplatten noch ausgepackt hatte,
Nochmal fleißig äh geliefert und das Sendezentrum hat alles online gestellt und äh vielen Dank an der Stelle auch nochmal an Ralf und Claudia, die sich im Nachgang des Kongresses da äh noch kräftig bemüht haben. Auch das
Projekt noch allumfänglich zu publizieren.
Ja, äh man sieht, glaube ich, an der Videoaufnahme, warum wir Audio Podcasts machen,
vier Radiogesichter, die sich hier die ganze Zeit in der Nase bohren und in eine andere Richtung gucken. Andre trinkt immer sein Bier, Gemüse genüsslich, wenn andere sprechen.
Ja, auch hübsch dekoriert mit Mütze und so. So kennt man ihn.
Ja, also die Mütze ist ja der Hauptgrund, warum er von der Polizei überwacht wird im NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss,
weißt du, kostet sogar an und wunderst dich, dass die sagen, behalte den Typen mal im Auge.
Ich habe ja äh einige Sendungen der Meta-Ebene ähm da auf die Bühne gebracht und äh die Reaktionen waren immer so, ja, oh Gott, meine Träume sind zerstört, alles anders. Ihr seid ja so alt und überhaupt und äh ich habe mir das ja ganz anders vorgestellt.
Ereigert mir noch keiner vorgeworfen.
Nee, das kommt noch. Keine Angst.
Ja, das dauert aber noch. Bei der bei der äh bei Lokbuchnetzpolitik zweihundertsechsundfünfzig.
Na, so wie wir hier schon vom Krieg erzählen, bisweilen, also das ist schon, kann man schon so einiges unterstellen.
Ja, ach ja, ne,
fühle ich mich noch nicht, also ja, weiß ich nicht. Also wenn ihr mich alt nennt, kriegt ihr auf die Fresse.
So sieht's nämlich aus.
So, ansonsten, ja, Videoaufzeichnung. Ja.
Genau. Anziehen, also falls ihr eure Träume behalten wollt, dann bleibt ihr halt einfach bei Audio only und ignoriert jetzt einfach diesen Hinweis, falls ihr aber schon immer mal äh sehen wolltet, was hier so Stamm äh die Stammkruse ausmacht,
Find das auch sehr, also ich bin ja sehr froh, dass wir irgendwie auch so ein Kernteam da auf die Bühne bekommen haben, nicht nur,
uns beide, sondern äh vor allem halt Andre und äh Thomas. Ähm,
Kapazität war da auch nicht auf der Bühne. Ähm mal schauen,
aber ich ich fühlte mich jetzt auch nicht entmutigt. Die die Idee von,
du weißt,
war, glaube ich, auch mit Video, haben wir, glaube ich, auch veröffentlicht, müssen wir mal gucken, ob das überhaupt noch online ist, aber.
Datenspuren.
Gab schon mal. Für so was immer zu haben,
Wenn die Veranstaltung, also ich finde, das passt gut auf solche netzpolitischen Veranstaltungen, die sagen wir mal, nicht nur jetzt verkopfte Diskussion haben wollen, sondern die auch für ein gewisses Entertainment äh Potenzial bieten, wie ich überhaupt,
sehr schön fand, dass dieser einunddreißigste, glaube ich, das erste Mal auch so eine Kategorie Entertainment hatte.
Nee, die gab's schon immer.
Immer? Nee, immer gab's die nicht.
Naja, die hieß Abendprogramm.
Ja, aber ist in gewisser Hinsicht eine sehr, sehr ehrliche äh Grundhaltung, weil das
einfach runter Entertainment zu packen und auch mal die Newshow da entsprechend einzusortieren. Also es ist schon äh.
Also es kann es kann sein, dass das oft dass die offiziell in aber also intern in der internen Planung gab's gab's glaube gibt's schon länger dann eben die Abend- und Nachtprogramms.
Ja, aber ich habe das erste Mal diese Kategorie, sagen wir mal, auch in, in, in, in digital gefasst, als.
Okay, das kann sein, das weiß ich.
Als als digitale Kategorie eines eines äh Fahrplanexports gesehen und ähm ja, insofern.
Und in der fühlst du dich wohl.
Ich fühle mich in der sehr wohl, weil das ja das, was die Metaebene macht, ja, also Entertainment mit Inhalt,
also könnte man das auch nennen, ich mag das Wort nicht, obwohl's eigentlich ganz gut passt,
wie wir ja letztes Mal schon äh bemerkt haben, so äh wie war das Zitat? Haben wir das überhaupt hier schon gebracht oder,
kannte ich bis dahin noch gar nicht. Ähm,
meinem eingestehen von äh äh Charlie Chaplin,
Äh ja und das trifft, glaube ich, hier die Grundhaltung von ganz gut.
Ich weiß nicht, siehst du das hier echt als Entertainment? Also mir macht das keinen Spaß.
Nö, aber Funny ist schon ein Ziel hier, also dafür bin ich ja da.
Funny what.
Na man darf halt,
man darf halt den Humor einfach nicht verlieren. Das ist einfach sehr wichtig, das werden wir jetzt auch gleich beim ersten Programmpunkt äh wieder sehen. Das ist so wenn man wenn man einfach auch nicht so eine so eine gewisse, man muss schon eine gewisse optimistische Grundhaltung haben,
Gegenüber dem dem dem Leben und dem Universum und dem ganzen Rest
A hilft es extrem dabei die Realität zu ertragen und äh B äh ist es äh einfach auch grundsätzlich äh
hilfreich auch sagen wir mal entsprechende Niederschläge äh gut ab,
zu fangen, ja? Also der Humor ist so ein bisschen der Prellbock äh der Realität und,
Kein Wunder, dass dass dass die bösen äh es auch jetzt auch den Kampf gegen den Humor ja so explizit aufgenommen haben. Wir werden in der letzten Sendung äh,
leider diskutieren mussten. Denn denn der Humor ist der eigentliche Feind des äh äh des der Diktatur.
Also man man sieht es immer wieder, also wenn wenn Leute sich aufraffen und einfach sagen,
Macht euch einfach mal hier äh zum Affen und wir zeigen euch auch einmal, wie ihr zum Affen das,
so ein verkopfter, verkopfter irgendwie inhaltlich orientierter, streng, seriös, argumentierender Mensch, der, der, der, der wird ja gar nicht ernst genommen. Aber wenn du halt äh
du schaffst, das Ganze auch noch irgendwie lustig rüberzubringen, dann na ja. Gut, ich meine, Charlie Chaplin hat jetzt insofern versagt bei Charlie App doof, weil,
Die waren vielleicht, vielleicht waren sie auch nicht Funny in Naff, weiß nicht, mein Französisch äh und meine Kenntnis über die französische Kultur äh ist da ich muss auch ehrlich zugestehen, also ich weiß nicht, wie es dir ging, aber mir war einfach Charlie im,
kein Begriff.
Nein, natürlich nicht. Das ist ein irgendwie ein Satiremagazin mit sechzigtausend Auflage. Das ist irgendwie.
Ja, aber das ist halt äh jetzt haben hat man sich ja auch durch viele Berichte äh reingehört und
ich habe auch in allen möglichen äh Podcastkanälen und Radio äh Beiträgen, die für Podcasts werden und Deutschlandfunk und auch ein paar anderen Sachen,
natürlich all diese Rückblicke und Erklärungsversuche mir angehört und auch als bei der Tag hat da sehr viel zu gebracht.
Welche Rolle das sozusagen gespielt hat, ne? Und äh abgesehen von diesem Magazin waren ja die Macher und vor allem eben auch die, die jetzt umgebracht wurden,
Teil der äh gesamtfranzösischen ähm Kultur,
als Person sehr sichtbar, auch im Fernsehen und,
einfach sozusagen aktive Begleiter, ja. In einem anderen ähm Bericht,
wurde gesagt, naja es wäre sehr schwer, das zu vergleichen, weil's so ein direktes Äquivualent nicht äh gibt, aber die die Auswirkung
des Attentats auf die französische Seele wäre vielleicht vergleich,
äh damit, wenn äh jetzt in Deutschland irgendwie eine Attentat auf äh Loriot,
worden wäre. Und ich kann dir sagen, da wäre ich aber auch richtig sauer gewesen.
Zum Glück.
Entzogen, aber äh.
Da haben wir Glück gehabt.
Ja, aber ich meine, wie wie würde, wie würde,
so gehen, wenn irgendwie das jetzt so äh luriose beiseite geschafft worden wäre. Also das das äh,
Auch noch einen französischen Namen, also.
Das hätte die Sache natürlich noch verkompliziert. Also ähm ich fand das jetzt, ich fand jetzt das, also wahrscheinlich.
Ich würde sagen, also loriot und der Fernsehturm. Ja, wenn die Terroristen sich das schaffen, dann dann wird einfach platt gemacht.
Die Terroristen den Fernsehturm wegmachen, die können sich bei mir ein Bier abholen.
Was?
Der Fernsehturm, den nervt, nein, den nein, der das war ein Scherz. Was nervt, was nervt an Berlin? Können wir mal kurz sagen, was, also was was an Berlin näher haft?
Ist der Fernsehturm?
Nein, das stimmt, der der Fernsehturm ist in Ordnung, der kann bleiben.
Wer muss bleiben?
Nee, hast du recht, der Fernsehturm ist in Ordnung,
Ja, nee, ist okay. Gibt kein Bier. Lass den Fernsehturm stehen,
Der Fernsehturm kann bleiben. Gibt gibt Schlimmeres. Es gibt schlimmeres als im Fernseh.
Genau,
Zum Beispiel unsere vergeblichen Versuche hier intelligenten Stück in die Sendung zu.
Vor allem unsere Versuche lustig zu sein. Du hast behauptet, wir wären lustig und du hast gerade gezeigt, wir sitzen nicht. Das ist meine These, die wir jetzt im Folgenden erörtern.
Ja, das darf dann in den Kommentaren dann äh dem darf dann in den Kommentaren widersprochen werden.
Ich wollte auch ganz kurz, weil weil du jetzt äh uns also Charlie und Loriot und was jetzt nicht alles rausgeholt hast, so ein Charlie Chaplin und so,
natürlich, das ist natürlich so die unsere Liga, ganz offen, offenbar. Ähm fand ich einen sehr interessanten ähm,
interessanten Text, äh den ich mal in den Shoutouts verlinke, den Text, wir sind nicht Charlie,
Fand ich sehr gut. Äh und ein Tweet, jetzt weiß ich nicht genau, von wem muss ich gleich auch nochmal verlinken, der da irgendwie so äh kursiert im Internet, den ich auch sehr gut finde. Ähm,
Ja komm, das machen wir jetzt noch ganz kurz. Dann machen wir mal hier live live Twittersuche. Wofür haben wir denn dieses Internet? Äh wo nämlich auch jemand sagt.
Weil's den Tanzartikel oder was? Also wir sind nicht verliebt, wenn ich jetzt hier verschiedenste.
Ja, wir sind, du musst ja auch immer in die Shownotes gucken, ne. Dann habe ich ja den Link ja schon drin. Ähm.
Ah ja. Den habe ich hier auch schon auf der.
Guck mal, dieses Twitter, das ist ja, kann man das hier mal sortieren, nach.
Also der sagt jemand ähm,
Da sagt jemand, äh sinngemäß, ich bin nicht Charlie, sondern ich bin der Polizist, der von den Angreifern erschossen wurde,
der in dieser äh Polizist war ja ein Muslim und der ist äh,
Quasi Charlie hat über Charlie Epdo hat seine Religion verarscht,
und dieser Polizist ist dabei gestorben, dass er das Recht von Charlie verteidigt hat,
dies zu tun. Das ist der wahre Held.
Frei nach Voltaire.
Vor allem, also ich habe die jetzt wahrscheinlich ungefähr äh zweihundertsechsundfünfzig Zeichen gebraucht, aber bei Twitter hat das jemand hinbekommen. In der englischen Sprache, in unter hundertvierzig Zeichen, das war sehr schön.
Ja, es ist wie Achmed heißt das entsprechende Hashtag zu.
Ach gibt's auch schon einen Hashtag zu.
Ja, das hat sich dann gleich am zweiten Tag da hinterhergewälzt. Das hat natürlich nicht denselben,
Da gibt's noch noch viele Aspekte, die man äh beleuchten kann. Man kann jetzt auch unzufrieden sein äh mit irgendwelchen Reaktionen oder was man vorher hätte machen,
können so.
Nein, nein, ich.
Auswirkungen sind noch unklar, ja? Und auch so diese Diskussion mit äh ob denn das jetzt sozusagen das französische ist,
Was ich finde sehr schwieriger Vergleich ist, aber der sich äh ja, den man sicherlich nicht,
Ähm ist halt noch nicht so ganz klar, wie die Politik reagieren wird, insbesondere auf die.
Also die französische.
Not. Die französische an sich, aber natürlich jetzt überhaupt Europa im Besonderen die Welt an sich. Ähm ja, damit sind wir ja jetzt im Prinzip auch schon fast äh beim ersten Thema. Wollen wir dann.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich würde nur bei all diesen Themen, die wir da sprechen und allen den kommenden Monaten, der Charlie Epto Reaktion,
äh denke ich, ist das Wichtigste, auf das er sich immer wieder äh zurück besinnen sollte ist, wie hätten denn diese Menschen auf diese Vorschläge reagiert?
Das finde ich also, ne, diese.
Welche Menschen, auf welche Vorschläge.
Die äh Charlie Epto Redaktion. Für welche Vorschläge die jetzt äh politischen Vorschläge, die jetzt herhalten müssen, das ist was hätten die dazu.
Ach so, ja, was hätten die dazu gesagt oder,
die sind ja auch noch nicht weg vom Fenster, sondern sie haben ja jetzt auch schon eine neue Ausgabe produziert
reduzierte, aber dafür äh mit Abstand die meistverkaufte.
Ja die war irgendwie zwei oder drei Millionen Auflage und irgendwie innerhalb von paar Stunden bei eBay. Also war natürlich sofort ausverkauft und bei eBay irgendwie im dreistelligen.
Ja, die produzieren irgendwie auch nach und so, klar, da muss jetzt jeder sich eins an die Wand kleben. Ähm.
Ja so ist das eben, ne? So ist die Aufmerksamkeit und so, ne. Da wird dann dann so ist das in der in unserer Ökonomie.
Und Gewinn zu machen, dann könnt's äh spannend werden.
Das ja genau, das kann man hoffen, weil hoffentlich, ja, ja, mal schauen. David Cameron ist einer von denjenigen, die jetzt mit dieser Angelegenheit äh Politik machen wollen,
Der hat eine sehr schöne Rede gehalten nach der Gedenkdemonstration in Folge der Anschläge in Paris, äh in der er dann eine zwölfmonatige Vorratsdatenspeicherung für Telefon und Internet fordert,
Und äh ich denke, da können wir jetzt mal einen O-Ton einspielen.
Ja, das können wir mal machen. Ganz modern hier.
Innerer Country.
Ja, ein Klassiker, würde ich sagen, ja. Das ist äh Hammer.
Standardsituationen der Netzpolitik.
Man muss, man muss äh eins vorweg, man muss äh kurz sehen,
in Großbritannien stehen Wahlen an im Mai,
Das ist jetzt sozusagen nochmal ein Faktor, den man mit einrechnen muss.
Ja, Großbritannien ist spannend. Also, wenn ich an äh Großbritannien und Verschlüsselung denke,
dann erinnere ich mich an den Fall vor, oh, das ist auch schön. Warte, doch, das weiß ich. Das war zweitausendelf, denn da habe ich ein Interview,
äh gegeben dem Deutschlandfunk vom Camp aus.
Vom CCC Kim. Also August äh,
August zweitausendelf muss das dann gewesen sein oder Juli,
da gab's doch Krawall in den in einigen Vierteln äh Englands und auch der Londons.
Mhm.
Die Riots, da haben sind die Leute. Ähm haben da äh geplündert und so, ne. Also es waren,
politischer Aufstände. Ich weiß noch nicht mal genau, welchen Hintergrund die äh hatten.
Ich grube auch jetzt gerade, was der Auslöser dafür war. Ähm,
auf jeden Fall schwer zur Sache in den Straßen, in den äh in mehreren Stadtteilen. Ich glaube, es ging vor allem von einem einzigen Stadtteil aus, in London,
war doch was mit SMS,
genau, ne?
Es ging los in Londoner Stadtteil. Tottenham, sechster August Friedriche Demonstrationen. Äh ach ja genau, guck mal, interessant. Äh Tod eines Einwohners bei einem Polizeieinsatz.
Ja, okay.
Also erinnert an an die Situation in,
In den USA, die wir jetzt äh täglich äh sehen, wo Menschen äh erschossen und erwürgt werden von der.
Beziehungsweise gab's ja, da gab's ja auch vor noch ein paar Jahren mehr in Los Angeles den großen Fall, ja, wo auch äh ein Schwarzer, glaube ich, wieder erschossen wurde von der Polizei und.
Also die Polizei in den USA erschießt jeden Tag mehrere schwarze.
Gefilmt wurde und so und deswegen, weiß nicht, Rodny King.
Nee, damals so. Wo, also wo es wirklich gebrannt hat, also wo wirklich komplette Straßenzüge verwüstet wurden, mehrere Häuser abgebrannt sind und so weiter. Nicht nur.
In England jetzt oder.
Nein, in Los Angeles jetzt.
Ach so, das weiß ich nicht genau.
Nur als Vergleich jetzt.
In ähm in äh am vierten August zweitausendelf war es Mark Duggen,
der bei einer geplanten Festnahme vom Polizeibeamten erschossen wurde.
Äh wurde verdächtigt für einen Drogenring zu arbeiten. Dann gab's irgendwie Demonstrationen. Das ging irgendwie äh auseinander und äh,
endete in wirklich ausführlichen ähm ausführlicher Randale,
Ähm und vor allem dann, was ja immer, dass das äh etwas traurige ist, wenn also ähm sagen wir mal,
marginalisierte, gesellschaftliche Schichten äh randalieren,
sich selber vor der Haustür zu machen. Ähm und quasi ihre eigenen ebenfalls marginalisierten ähm,
kleinen Einkaufsladenbetreiber irgendwie äh zu plündern oder so, ne? Aber das jetzt alles,
außen vor, worauf ich eigentlich hinaus will, ist ähm
zweitausendelf.
In in äh in Großbritannien war sehr verbreitet, dass Blackberry und ein sehr beliebter Kommunikationsdienst war der Blackberry Messenger,
Ja und also kann man sich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen. Ah ja, ja, gibt's noch, aber also das war halt, das war halt das Ding. Und das war ähm,
ein oder hat so ein System, das ist alles verschlüsselt,
zum Blackberry Server. Also du, du holst dir du kaufst dir quasi mit diesem, dieses Blackberry-System kurz zusammengefasst ist äh voll verschlüsselt.
Zu dem Preis, dass du dir äh den den Blackberry Server als Menende reinholst, ja? Ähm und es ist also nicht Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, aber ähm so verschlüsselt, dass du, sagen wir mal,
in ein dich in ein nicht vertrauenswürdiges Netz begeben kannst und nur vertrauen musst.
Und dann äh brach die Story
dass sich nämlich diese Randalierer per Blackberry Messenger verabreden würden und koordinieren würden. Das ist also wie WhatsApp oder so, da gab's dann auch Gruppen oder so. Und äh dass sie quasi dieses System nutzten,
um sich zu äh,
zu koordinieren und da ähm zu randalieren. Und die hatten natürlich einen relativ schlechten äh Ruf in in der äh in der Lügenpresse, in der politischen Lüge und Systempresse. Und ähm entsprechend,
führte das relativ schnell zu, also zu dieser, zu einer relativ großen Meldung, so, ja, hier. Das blackberry-System hilft dabei, ähm dass diese, dass diese Randalierer sich koordinieren. Und,
Blackberry hat dann sehr schnell ähm mit einer Pressemitteilung geantwortet, dass sie mit den UK-Behörden ab jetzt zusammenarbeiten und denen.
Den Zugriff auf diese Nachrichten ermöglichen wollen,
was für die tatsächlich positiv sich auswirkte in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung,
Während man ja normalerweise sagen müsste, so wat! Bitte!
Ihr verkauft hier irgendwie ein sicheres System und bei der bei der ersten Zeitungsmeldung
Und äh das ist das, woran ich mich erinnere, wenn wir von verschlüsselter Kommunikation,
äh Großbritannien sprechen,
So und er sagt also jetzt ähm David Cameron sagt, wir wollen in Extremis, also im Extremfall.
In Notsituationen.
In Notsituationen, genau. Mit einem persönlich unterschriebenen äh also Befehlbeschluss, der,
es, warte mal, home secotary ist Innenminister, ne? Nee, Innen
was ist eigentlich Home Secret? Ähm müsste man mal kurz schauen.
Das ist mal wieder äh eine sehr englisch spezi.
Innenminister also Innenminister. Oder?
Könnte man sagen. England und. Interessanterweise. Hat auch Immigration und äh.
Staatsbürger Straße. Ja.
Staatsbürgerschaft sozusagen. Also weiß ich nicht, ob das sich,
eins zu eins auf Innenministerium übersetzen lässt.
Na ja, aber wenn es um also in Deutschland wäre es ja auch, dass Innenministerium bei dem äh Grundrechtseinschränken.
Aber Polizei, National Security, also das denke ich mal, aber auch äh äh ist da untergeordnet, also ja.
Also das Äquivalent zum Innenminister.
Genau. Ein denkbares Äquivalent.
Und die sollen also im Extremfall,
ähm jedes Kommunikations abhören wollen und der äh können. Und er sagt ja jetzt auch so bei Telefon machen wir das bei bei allem, was wir haben, machen wir das. Aber können wir ein System erlauben und das ist der entscheidende Satz.
Bei dem wir das einfach nicht können. Also,
das heißt,
bei denen sich der Betreiber weigern würde.
Möchte ich noch anmerken, dass manche das vielleicht viel interpretieren, also es muss nicht, sondern das heißt.
Dürfen unter keinen Umständen dürfen wir es erlauben, dass es eine ähm,
ein Kommunikationssystem gibt, bei dem wir nicht in der Lage sind, es abzuhören.
Bald ist es ja unsere Aufgabe als Staat und das ist überhaupt die wichtigste Aufgabe ist der Staat ja für die Sicherheit sorgt.
So, jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, äh.
Was in UK auch nicht in der Verfassung steht, weil da steht überhaupt nichts in der Verfassung. Es gibt keine.
Kann sich kein, kein Land vorstellen, in dem es so einen guten Schutz gegen,
wie nicht okay, also ich bitte euch, ja.
Das ist das ist wirklich überhaupt der Knaller, ja. Äh das ist aber das Problem, dass ich äh äh UK, also die können sich andere Länder sowieso nicht vorstellen, weil äh das ist ja dann unser Kontinent.
Ja, also klar, also jetzt, wenn man sich überlegt, auf ihrer Insel sind sie das.
Also weder Wales, noch England, noch Schottland, soweit Erkenntnis davon hat, ist das jetzt irgendwie anders, ja?
Und so weiter, da können wir da wahrscheinlich mal drüber reden, da gibt's bestimmt nochmal ein paar Sonder äh Bedingungen, aber soweit dies zur Kenntnis gekommen ist, also die vier Länder, die es gibt,
Ja
Also das ist ja kein Land. Na ja, also die Frage ist natürlich,
Nehmen wir, nehmen wir den Mann jetzt mal kurz ernst, denn der ist ja ähm,
ernst zu nehmen, weil er gefährlich ist. So und er also seine Idee ist, also stellen wir uns jetzt mal vor, also er sagt mit anderen Worten, wir erlauben,
keine nicht abhörbare Kommunikation.
Würden wir gerne nicht erlauben.
Ja, genau, möchten wir nicht erlauben und zieht damit sogar in den Wahlkampf. Ja, also das das sagt ja schon eine Menge aus
über äh immer auch die wie sicher er sich mit dieser Angelegenheit ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass das eine CDU,
sich trauen würde, mit so einer Forderung in den Wahlkampf zu gehen. Ja, vielleicht überschätze ich da auch irgendwie unsere Einflussmöglichkeit.
Das das werden wir jetzt noch sehen, wie, wie, wie, wie die CDU sich da jetzt wirklich verhält. Lass mal die CDU erstmal raus.
So, aber jetzt sagt er, okay, keine keine,
Kommunikation,
Und jetzt ist die Frage, also die die Forderung ist relativ einfach. Wie möchte er sie aber umsetzen,
verhindern können wird er es nicht, dass es dass diese Tools erhältlich sind, ja? Ähm,
Also es geht natürlich irgendwie um äh.
Also Schlüssel hinterlegung, dass sie quasi Zugriff bekommen, wenn sie sie haben wollen. Dass die Verschlüsselung,
besten Fall Oversize Air nach wie vor schwer zu äh,
abzuhören ist von Dritten, aber wenn sie darauf Zugriff bekommen wollen, dann entweder über solche Backdoors, wie wir das mit,
eben schon diskutiert haben oder eben schon äh als als ähm gezielte
Schwächung des Verschlüsselungsmechanismuses, in dem halt sozusagen jeder Key immer noch so eine Hintertür äh automatisch mit eingebaut hat. Sind ja die alten USA-Ideen.
Das wäre die, das wäre die intelligenteste Lösung für das Problem. Na, er könnte es natürlich auch einfach verbieten. Also ähm,
in den in den UK-Berichterstattungen geht's dann auch so um so Systeme wie Snapchat,
und WhatsApp, ja? WhatsApp ja jetzt auch mit.
Verschlüsselung kommt.
Mit der Texte Verschlüsselung äh eine Lösung hat, die äh Ende zu Endeverschlüssung ermöglicht. Ähm.
Message.
Ja, wobei da bin ich, also ich meine also,
für für diese kommerziellen Anbieter,
halte ich diese Gesetzgebung also da wäre mir das egal, denn
ich traue denen auch heute noch nicht, dass sie ihre Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung so machen, dass da keine Regierungen der Welt zugreifen kann. Insofern wäre mir das als äh wäre mir das egal. Also ich ich
benutze Eye-Message nicht als ein,
Ende zu Ende verschlüsseltes Medium und vertraue ihm auch nicht als ein Ende zu Ende des Medium. Weil,
für mich auch keinen Anlass gibt. Ich kann meinen Schlüssel da nicht selber bestimmen, also warum sollte ich äh so ich meine
Es gibt keinen Anlass, diesem System jetzt, als als ein ernsthaft Ende zu Ende verschlüsseltes Medium zu trauen.
Gut, dass seh ich auch ein, aber es ist halt derzeit auch ein Sales-Augugument, der großen Firmen und wir haben ja gesehen, dass der Widerstand aus Silicon Valley gegenüber ähm,
Appelmaßnahmen der NSA ähm relativ stark ist, weil die einfach keinen Bock haben, sich da den Markt verhauen zu lassen.
Richtig. Ähm,
So, jetzt, jetzt gehen wir, also jetzt stellen wir uns vor, die Briten gehen hin und sagen, Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Kommunikation,
dass wir da eingreifen können, ist nicht erlaubt.
Jetzt stellt sich natürlich die also das das würde als allererstes mal die Unternehmen betreffen, die in diesem Land Dienste
anbieten. Da würde also Apple sich einen schönen sauberen Rückkanal für ihre Keys machen. WhatsApp auch und ähm denn irgendwie bei Aktivierung in Großbritannien das dann machen
müssen
Ja, wer ja gesetzt, würden sie sich auch dran, sagen wir mal, gehen wir mal Adler von aus, daran würden sie sich halten. Was machst du jetzt mit den Leuten, die ähm,
sage ich mal, ernstzunehmende Verschlüsselungssysteme benutzen, die in ihrer eigenen Hand sind, also OTR,
ähm erstmal PGP. So,
auf eigener Basis, wie,
finden die Briten überhaupt raus, dass du denen grade nicht den Kiel gegeben hast,
Ja, also wenn,
Es könnte ja sein, dass ich denen eine Mail geschrieben habe. Ey übrigens, hier ist mein Secret Griff für,
Dann könnt ihr äh euch da die die Unterschrift äh abholen und das Ding abhören,
Das heißt, sie müssten eigentlich, wenn sie es ernst meinen, diesen diese die gesamte Technik verbieten. Und das können sie wiederum nicht.
Oder können sie schon, aber dann hätten sie auf jeden Fall aller Hände voll zu tun, weil das natürlich die Leute wie die Irren benutzen würden dann.
Weil das wäre wiederum auch die das das wirkliche Zugeben, dass sie dass sie das Tool nicht,
dass sie das nicht klappen können, ja? Also das ist ja zum einen eine der Strategien ist ja auch, dass die NSA eigentlich nicht will oder keiner der Geheimdienste wirklich möchte, ähm.
Dass die Nutzer wissen, was die Geheimnisse knacken können und was nicht.
Wäre ja scheiße, wenn also wenn du jetzt sagen wir mal der, sagen wir mal, dass äh,
deutsche Strafverfolgungsbehörden könnten tru cript knacken oder nicht knacken,
Beide Informationen würden Sie nicht wirklich öffentlich dokumentiert haben wollen. Weil wenn man weiß, Sie können's knacken, würde es keiner mehr nutzen.
Wenn man weiß, dass es nicht knacken können.
Wenn sie bestätigen, dass sie es nicht knacken können, würden es alle nutzen, ja? Also,
wollen sie diese Information nicht rausgeben. Das heißt, es ist also der scheint wirklich nicht,
Also entweder ist er blöd oder er hat die,
Naja gut, man kann ihm nichts zu, man man sollte ihm nicht von ihm verlangen, dass er sich in dem Materie auskennt. Aber die Frage ist, seine Berater werden ihm sicherlich schon gesagt haben, so, dass diese Forderung eigentlich nicht,
dass es nicht möglich ist, diese Forderung umzusetzen.
Muss ja auch nicht unbedingt. Ist Wahlkampf. Also es geht jetzt dadrum, dass,
zu fordern, ja?
Den Eindruck zu machen, dass äh was getan wird. Ich meine, wir wir befinden uns einfach in der in der Phase des äh Aktionismus, nicht,
damit will ich nicht sagen, politischen Forderungen vor Wahlkämpfen folgt niemals auch eine Umsetzung, ja, äh,
Kann natürlich sein, auch wenn's hier technische Hürden gibt, äh in gewisser Hinsicht ist es so albern, weil natürlich, wie wir alle wissen, GCA,
HQ und NSA äh in voller Bandbreite alles dafür,
tun, um alles das, was,
vermeintlich nicht entschlüsselbar ist, trotzdem zu entschlüsseln über alle möglichen Wege, über viel über die wir hier gesprochen haben, viel über die Vorträge und Dokumente äh bekannt geworden sind. Also sie tun das ja eh,
sie versuchen das E.
Genau, deswegen ähm also das sind die beiden, das sind ja die beiden Aspekte. Einmal,
technische Hintergrund, es ist letztendlich nicht möglich, das zu verhindern
Er kann es verbieten, ja? Also könnte jetzt irgendwie sowas machen. Keine Ahnung, soweit irgendwie die hören halt einfach die ganze Zeit deinen ab und wenn da,
wenn sie sehen, dass du ein OTR äh Handshake machen willst, dann äh treten sie die Tür ein und hauen die auf die Fresse. So, ne? Also dat machen sie einen Monat lang und schon hat sich das Problem äh
in einen in einen kleinen erträglichen Rahmen äh reduziert. So, ähm das heißt also von der technischen Seite ist es nicht,
ist es letztendlich nicht sinnvoll durchsetzbar. Ja, sie so. Jetzt gehen wir aber mal auf die,
Stellen wir uns mal vor, es, sie würden es durchsetzen,
dass sie quasi sagen, okay, wir wir verhindern das,
Effektiv und verbieten das und wir machen, wir bringen ein paar Leute vor Gericht und wir machen ein paar,
ein paar Präzedenzfälle. So. Dann.
Muss man sich ja mal überlegen, was das für die äh was es grundsätzlich bedeutet für das Land, wenn sie sagen, okay, ihr dürft nicht.
Ihr dürft euch eigentlich nicht grundsätzlich gegen Abhören schützen,
Das wäre ja ein, also würde er das wirklich umsetzen. Das wäre eine Katastrophe für das ganze Land.
Ja, für die, vor allem für die Wirtschaft und den Finanzsektor, also vollkommen unvorstellbar, ja.
Finanzsektor in in Großbritannien, der darf eh keinerlei äh bei denen muss alle Kommunikationen dokumentiert sein. Äh wegen Insider-Hand ist nochmal was anderes, aber die haben, die haben, also die dürfen ähm
quasi Analysten und Trader in Großbritannien,
müssen einen kompletten Trail von ihrer gesamten Kommunikation irgendwie haben,
für ähm für die Finanzaufsicht,
Das ist nochmal eine, die sind sowieso schon Fakt. So, aber äh das ist auch nochmal eine eine andere Geschichte.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, es gibt ja auch wirtschaftliche Aktivitäten jenseits des Tradings und äh der unmittelbaren Finanz äh Transaktionen äh,
jetzt halt Firmen untereinander Verträge austauschen et cetera und dann würde ihnen jetzt die Verschlüsselung verbieten, also das das da da laufen die Amok
So, wir haben die jetzt auch verstanden.
Das heißt, die Forderung ist.
Unhaltbar.
Ist unhaltbar und.
Wäre sie irgendwie jede jeder Schritt, der in die Nähe dieser dieser Realisierung käme, wäre halt ein Albtraum.
Und jetzt frage ich mich, was ist das für ein Land Tim? Du hast so einen Pass von diesem Land? Äh,
Indem du ernsthaft so eine Forderung stellen kannst und das auch noch im Wahlkampf machst und das auch noch irgendwie,
irgendwie quasi wirklich in in der direkten Folge auf diese Anschläge,
Und darauf hoffen kannst, da mit irgendjemandem irgendwie auch noch zu beeindrucken.
Naja, ist ja nun keine Neuigkeit, dass sich bei den UK äh,
um die fleischgewordene äh Ohrwäsche Vision handelt,
man das Landes einfach äh zugestopft mit Kameraüberwachung und äh hat generell ein sehr die Gesellschaft ist ja generell sehr staats äh
ja, da gibt's aber auch noch mehr Schichten, mehr Klassen
System, das ist in gewisser Hinsicht, dass England ja auch noch sehr, sehr, sehr rückständig so in der gesellschaftlichen Entwicklung. Wir hatten da auch mal eine andere Phase, aber davon ist jetzt relativ wenig übrig geblieben. Also
das irgendwie alles in äh in eine andere Richtung und ähm ich habe,
ehrlich gesagt wenig,
Hoffnung. Ja und äh,
was wir jetzt über die Aktivitäten des äh GCHQ und auch das Verhältnis, sagen wir mal zur Öffentlichkeit und Meinungsfreiheit. Ich meine, ich erinnere nur an diese Festplattenaktion da mit dem Guardian et cetera äh gehört haben, zeigt ja, dass dass das einfach alles äh
Sie können da tausendmal wissen, Charlie hinschreiben, die sind einfach nicht Charlie. Also David Cameron ist auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht Charlie.
Nee, das stimmt. David Cameron ist nicht Charlie.
Will ja auch Charlie Cameron heißen. Ja, äh wir sind David. Ja. Also wie gesagt, ich ich seh's insofern.
Fühle mich jetzt noch nicht sonderlich,
beunruhigt über das normale Beunruhigungsmaß hinaus, durch diese äh Äußerung, weil ich sehe sie halt klar A im Kontext der Wahlen, der mit Cavenron Cameron ist,
ohnehin äh auf vielen, an vielen Ebenen ähm,
innenpolitisch unter Feuer. Ja, das ist jetzt nicht nur diese Terror- und Sicherheitsgeschichte, ist halt natürlich auch grundsätzlich die ganzen NSA-Revolutions, die glaube ich in in England keine große,
Diskussion hochgebracht haben, soweit ich das wahrnehmen kann, also sicherlich nicht in irgendeiner Form vergleichbar mit dem wie die Diskussion in Deutschland gelaufen ist und da sind wir ja schon tot. Und dazu kommt halt auch noch äh der Stress, den sie mit Schottland
äh haben und dass er äh möglichst äh noch im nächsten,
Jahr halt dieses EU-Referendum auf den Weg bringen kann
diese generelle Kontra-Haltung, die ist da einfach sehr verbreitet und ähm,
der gemeine britische Staatsbürger ist halt sehr in in Solar.
Im täglicher, erträglicher Hinsicht. Verallgemeinerung kommen, aber ich meine, das ist ja nun wirklich keine Neuigkeit.
Äh ich habe dich jetzt nicht ganz verstanden. Meinst du damit, dass er, weil er unter Druck steht,
Forderung erhebt oder weil er weil er merkt.
Tut natürlich jetzt alles um irgendwie wir erleben hier einfach klassischen Aktionismus
genau das. Das ist das, was interessanterweise noch nicht in Frankreich noch nicht in dem Maße äh gestartet hat. Äh ich weiß nicht, wer mir auch noch oft äh in Deutschland zu sprechen kommen, ja, klar, was Vorratsdatenspeicherung betrifft. Hier geht's jetzt halt langsam los,
es muss auch was getan äh werden, es kann auch nicht sein, dass et cetera, also diese ganzen Wortmeldungen gibt es ja jetzt schon, ne, nur gibt's halt jetzt gerade noch so eine Pietätspause von äh einer Woche
die Situation auszunutzen so, das haben sie jetzt alle gelernt, man muss da mal eine Woche die Schnauze halten,
David Cameron hat halt das Memo nicht bekommen und äh hat jetzt einfach nur noch ein paar Monate bis zur Wahl und er muss halt jetzt gleich austeilen.
Da ist er jetzt nicht der einzige. Wir fangen ja nur bei ihm jetzt an. Also.
Einzige in UK.
Okay, der der einzige in UK vielleicht, aber der nicht da.
Also sicherlich auch nicht der einzige in UK, ja. Ich meine, er hat ja dann auch noch äh äh das Problem, ähnlich wie auch in Frankreich mit dem Frauen National, nicht in dem selben
Maße, aber so diese äh Independence Party in äh okay, die macht natürlich dann auch vom rechten Rand ordentlich Stimmung und äh jetzt geht's halt dadrum, wer's äh wer darf als erstes ähm,
sprechend den harten Typen geben so.
Ich verstehe das, ich verstehe das, Tim und ähm ich freue mich auch immer, dass du wie wie ausführlich du das alles mit der Rückständigkeit der Insel
erklären kannst das ändert auch nichts daran, dass dass der Mensch offensichtlich in der Lage ist so 'ne Forderung zu stellen.
Ja, ich bin jetzt nur gespannt, wem gegenüber er sie jetzt denn eigentlich durchsetzen möchte, also,
Ebene sehe ich da ehrlich gesagt keine äh Chancen, weil der hat einfach die UK derzeit auch einfach einen zu schlechten Stand in Europa
und ähm innerhalb von UK, ja, wie gesagt, weiß ich gar nicht, ob's überhaupt noch einen großen Unterschied ausmachen würde.
Na ja, ich denke, wir können das jetzt an der Stelle auch einfach so stehen lassen, ja. Also er hat das jetzt gesagt, äh das ist nichts, wovon wir jetzt sonderlich überrascht sein sollten, dass solche Wortmeldungen kommen.
Wir schätzen das ein als technisch und auch
praktisch, allein schon wegen der Wirtschaft äh undurchsetzbar,
geht's aber erstmal darum, der Erste gewesen zu sein, der jetzt irgendwie sagt, man muss doch mal was tun und äh
Könnte man doch auch gleich mal irgendwas legalisieren, was hier sowieso hinten rum sowieso die ganze Zeit versuchen.
Noch dazu kommt natürlich, dass bis jetzt der Nachweis aussteht, dass diese das verschlüsselte Kommunikation überhaupt irgendein,
Relevanz für diese Anschläge gehabt hätte.
Exakt. Das hat jetzt auch wieder mal gar nichts damit zu tun wahrscheinlich.
Ja
Ja, aber es ist, es ist mit mit Sorge zu ähm betrachten, dass es offensichtlich ihm gelingt, eine solche Forderung ähm zu stellen, ohne,
dass er am Lachtest der eigenen Bevölkerung scheitert.
In Deutschland gibt's auch schöne Forderungen, ja. Ja, ja.
Mhm. Ja, da ist jetzt die Karenzzeit rum, ne?
Ja, aber die war ja, die war ja tatsächlich in Deutschland sehr schnell, um äh die ähm es war ja in Deutschland so,
die man zählen kann, ne? Das ist auf dieses Verlass.
Wenn ich das jetzt, wenn ich das richtig erinnere. War sicherlich noch jemand. Ähm.
Ja, Schäuble ist dann ein paar Tage später noch mit äh eingeschert und äh meinte er auch, man müsste ja was machen.
Genau, aber das da musst du nämlich drauf schauen, wie die das machen. Die schicken erst äh warte mal.
Erst die Beißer vor, ne, die sowieso äh für nichts anderes bekannt sind. Die setzen dann erstmal den Ton, dann wird geguckt, wie wir das jetzt zitiert. Ah, okay, die Zeitungen drucken das auch,
äh Bosbach war jetzt schon mal der erste, wie immer.
Und äh das fand ich dann schon bemerkenswert, dass sich sogar Schäuble geäußert hat, weil ich habe so den Eindruck gehabt, dass in letzter Zeit, dass er sich eigentlich jetzt so ein bisschen auf seinem Finanzstuhl da äh gut eingerichtet hat,
seiner alten Innenminister äh Avance nicht unbedingt äh wieder aus der Tasche holen muss,
Ist wohl nicht so. Und wer äh mir allerdings sehr,
aufgefallen ist, ist äh nach wie vor, äh also ich,
ne? Also jeder kann sich da auch drehen, aber bisher finde ich die,
äh Äußerungen von Heiko Maas,
nicht nur im Hinblick auf die Fortzahlenspeicherung. Bemerkenswert.
Also er zeigt da relativ viel Statur, was seine Grundhaltung gegenüber Vorratsdatenspeicherung betrifft, weil er halt auch gleich gesagt hat, so, ja das verhindert die diese Anschläge nicht und äh,
ich mache da nichts.
Dann irgendwann schaltete sich die,
also genau. Uhl Bosbach, CDU CSU,
relativ gleichzeitig sagte, ähm haben die nämlich den Heiko Maas,
direkt gestachelt und gesagt, ey, Heiko Maas muss jetzt endlich liefern, äh und äh
es dürfe keine Toleranz und kein Nachlassen im weltweiten Kampf gegen die Finanzierung und Unterstützung des äh Terrorismus geben, ja? Also die greifen die haben denen quasi haben da bei ihm auf den Busch geklopft. Er hat dann
Äh wie du sagtest auch sehr besonnen,
reagiert erstmal. Heiko Maas ist aber auch SPD. So,
Das war quasi der der Auftakt zu diesem Spiel. Dann kam ein paar Tage später
Angela Merkel und sagt, Fordseitensprechung, so müssen wir jetzt echt mal gucken, ne? Vorratsdatenspeicherung heißt ja jetzt auch nicht mehr Vorzeitenspeicherung, sondern die CDU arbeitet ja seit einiger Zeit schon daran, ähm das Ganze als äh Mindestspeicherfristen umzulabeln,
Habe ich übrigens auch einen sehr schönen äh Tweet von äh äh.
Speicherfriss.
Ja ja. Na da sind sie klar, also ähm,
sind sie sehr drum bemüht, ist ja auch klar. Ich meine, Vorratsdatenspeicherung der.
Ich finde, die können erstmal, die können erstmal den Mindestspeicherfrist bei dem öffentlichen Rundfunk einführen.
Ja, ja klar. Ähm aber hier, schau mal, das das fand ich sehr interessanter Gast, nämlich der ähm,
Thomas Jarzombek, CDU, einer der dort eher progressiv progressiveren
und auch kompetenteren Netzpolitiker sagte irgendwie Merkel spricht sich gemeinsam mit den Innenministern der Länder für Mindestspeicherfristen aus in einer von zehn Punkten der Regierungserklärung. Dann wurde ihm auf Twitter geantwortet, von Thomas Stadler, dem Rechtsanwalt,
Thomas antwortete in einem
freien Land ist jeder frei seine Begrifflichkeiten zu wählen, Smiley. Und das ist schon interessant, weil ihm natürlich klar ist,
ähm also,
Das ist halt ein Berufspolitiker, ne? Der weiß schon
was da abgeht. Und der weiß natürlich auch, dass dieser Begriff ursprünglich von ihnen kam, vorwärts, Datenspeicherung. Ja, das war ja mal ein Begriff, den den gab's einfach. Den war ja nicht klar, dass ihn der irgendwann mal so um die Ohren fliegen würde, ja? Und so negativ besetzt werden wird. Also ändern Sie jetzt diesen Begriff.
Hast du gerade gesagt, wer den erfunden hat oder nein? Wer Jazzombeck hat den erfunden.
Ja, doch, oder nicht. Also nein, aber die also der Begriff wurde doch,
prägt ursprünglich äh von denjenigen, die dieses die dieses Projekt auch sich ausgedacht haben oder.
Ja, aber ich weiß gar nicht mehr, ob wir also das wäre mal interessant, herauszufinden, wer sich den eigentlich ausgedacht hat, falls das jemand weiß, bitte in die Kommentare. Ist jetzt nicht so wichtig.
Machen wir jetzt äh nee, nee, nee. Aber ich ich find's auf jeden Fall interessant, dass dass er da sehr ähm,
sehr offen auch damit umgeht, dass sie gerade versuchen, diesen Begriff umzulabeln und dass ihnen das durchaus,
bekannt ist, ja? Dass welche, welchen Versuch sie da gerade machen. Ähm.
Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall haben sich dann noch weitere äh zur Wort gemeldet,
Also Merkel hast du jetzt schon erwähnt, Schäuble äh erwähnt, äh unser Innenminister.
Und jetzt kann man schön äh Sigmar Gabriel beim Umkippen zusehen, denn der.
Thomas war doch auch noch äh schnell, aber.
Ja, man hätte ja auch das Maul halten können, hat aber nicht.
Nicht. Nein, aber der ist ja auch schon seit einiger Zeit also wir erinnern uns, der von dir gelobte Heiko Maas hat ja schon öfter mal einen Einlauf von Thomas de Maizire bekommen.
Ja. Scheint ihm aber irgendwie noch nicht richtig mundtot gebracht zu haben. Finde ich ganz bemerkenswert.
Äh ja ähm.
Genau, aber jetzt kommt äh jetzt kommt Gabriel und sagt ja, also ne. Müssen wir jetzt gucken, weil ähm.
Genau. Unter bestimmten Bedingungen. Unter bestimmten Bedingungen.
Setz dich dann unter bestimmten Bedingungen, ja.
Ist immer, das ist geil, also wenn die wenn die bei unter bestimmten Bedingungen,
weißt du, okay, das ist jetzt der, jetzt geht's los.
Also schwierig ist zum Beispiel die Bedingungen der Realität.
Andere Bedingungen könnten das vielleicht ändern.
Die SPD hat durch die Beschlüsse ihres Bundesparteitags und ihrer Bundestagsfraktion klar beschrieben, unter welchen Engeln verfassungsrechtlichen Voraussetzungen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ein geeignetes und verhältnismäßiges Instrument zur Strafverfolgung sein kann.
Hat ja der SZ gesagt. Es wäre gut, wenn die Vorschläge, die von der damaligen Bundesregierung verworfen wurden, jetzt sorgfältig beraten würden,
in alter Reflexe zu zurückzufallen.
Ja
Ich weiß noch nicht ganz genau, wie wie groß seine Neigung gerade ist äh ja, also ob er jetzt schon so,
Schiefertop von Pisa oder weiter äh ist. Ich meine es gibt halt die die Äußerungen, also die die Sprachregelung,
Heiko Maas anders umsetzt als ein Sigmar Gabriel ist ja immer,
verstanden haben, dass glaube ich alle, die CDU lässt sie diesen Punkt aus der Debatte heraus und sagt, kann ja nicht sein, dass und die SPD sagt, na ja, man könnte ja über alles nachdenken, aber die EU.
Ja, das sagt aber Gaurriel auch. Also Gabriel sagt, wir wollen, ach so, okay. Alles klar. Also, Heiko Maas sagt,
in Deutschland gescheitert. Das ist in der EU gescheitert und es ist sowieso Unsinn, also lasst uns mal hier irgendwie äh zurück an die Arbeit,
ja die haben gesehen, dass es in Deutschland gescheitert und in der EU jetzt müssen wir es auf EU-Ebene klären,
Damit war das einheitlich und sauer und.
Ist halt auch Vizekanzler. Äh ist Vizekanzler, er muss, er muss,
Die sitzen, ich weiß ja nicht, wie das so genau läuft, aber ich meine, die haben da ihre Kabinettssitzung und die haben natürlich auch so ihre Kanzlerebene und äh selbstverständlich sind die immer darum bemüht
'ne Sprachregelung zu finden wo jeder sein Gesicht wahren kann. So,
der Vizekanzler wart auch das Gesicht der Kanzlerin,
mit, ja, weil er kann jetzt nicht sagen, die Kanzlerin erzählt äh,
und riecht nach Lulu, weil das ja fucking Vizekanzler. Macht er nicht. Dafür ist er zu klug.
Oder zu blöd, weil ich meine, wenn du wenn du erstmal Vizekanzler in einer großen Koalition bist, musst du natürlich irgendwie auch daran denken, dass du nächstes Jahr keine nächste Legislatur keine große Koalition mehr haben willst.
Ja, aber wenn nicht, der Kanzler bin und du bist der Vizekanzler, dann musst du ja auch ein bisschen.
Wieso bist du denn jetzt der Kanzler und nicht ich.
Scheiß drauf, wenn dich der Vizekanzler Pandier bin, dann würde ich auch ein bisschen Rücksicht auf dich nehmen, aber das überleg mir das grad nochmal.
Also, spannend ist, ich ich finde ja die Sprachregelung sehr interessant, ja, weil er dann sagt, ähm,
Und das ist da, da kann man nämlich jetzt genau sehen, wie dieses Spiel gespielt wird. Du hast also deine deine kleine Fascho-Clique da irgendwie, die schickst du erst mal vor. Die schreien erstmal groß rum. Dann.
Die Minions.
Ja. So, wollte ich an der Stelle kann man auch noch kurz erwähnen,
Da gibt's ja dann auch eine ähm es gibt ja irgendwie äh also es gibt eine,
Erklärung dann auch von CCC digitale Gesellschaft, republikanischer Anwälteverein und Humanistische Union. Wenn ich mich jetzt recht entsinne,
habe ich ein bisschen dran mitformuliert äh neben vielen anderen, deswegen ist er auch eine gemeinsame Erklärung. Ähm,
Wo also sich genau gegen diese äh Schnellschüsse und so gewendet wird, ja, wo gesagt wird, ey, also diese Forderungen sind Unsinn und äh verhöhnen das Leid der Opfer und so weiter. Ja, also die das, was wir hier ja auch schon zu Genüge besprochen haben,
Und wie sich jetzt nämlich wie sich Gabriel jetzt positioniert, ist der sagt.
Erstmal grundsätzlich jo. Garniert das aber mit,
Es bringt nun nichts Hals über Kopf in Deutschland alleine einen neuen Gesetzentwurf auf den Weg
zu bringen, der dann wieder vom Europäischen Gerichtshof kassiert wird, stattdessen müssen wir uns mit,
auf mit der europäischen Ebene abstimmen, sonst droht ja auch der nächste Gesetzesentwurf aus Deutschland vor Gericht kassiert zu werden, schnellst
schnell äh Schüsse zur politischen Profilierung helfen nicht weiter. Ja, der das heißt, der der stellt sich jetzt als der Besonnene dar,
Und äh Merkel ja auch, ne, so in dem,
Dann haste den Heiko Maas, der, der, der einzige ist, der da irgendwie noch mit Sinn und Verstand agiert, den kriegst du aber dann irgendwie kriegst du dadurch, dass du als Sigma Gabriel dich in Richtung besonnen,
bewegst und dich dann schön in der Süddeutschen Zeitung, so, ne, porträtierst und so,
bist also der besondere Sigmar Gabriel, das versteht ja jeder, ne? Der Sigmar Gabriel, der will das hier auf Sicht fahren und so, ne?
Und der Heiko Maas seit Jahren äh äh kommt ja immer wieder mit dem gleichen Argument, fällt dem kein neues Argument ein, so ne, jetzt hier zwölf Leute tot und so, ne,
So wir, so werden solche Sachen gespielt,
So werden solche Sachen gespielt und jetzt sagen sie, müssen wir erstmal auf die EU warten und so, ne? Und ähm am Ende sitzen dann Gabriel und Merkel.
Wann genau der Extremposition.
An der gesellschaftlichen Extremposition, wo sie hinwollten und das ist so dieser, diese immer wieder gleiche Möglichkeit und so funktioniert quasi die diese gesamte Politik der,
von Angela Merkels Regierung und auch jede andere Politik eigentlich, wenn man sich das so
vor äh vorstellt, aber hier kann man's sehr gut sehen, dass du quasi,
Einfach ein paar nützliche Deppen in der dritten Reihe brauchst,
die sowas wie die Extremflanken definieren,
Und jemanden, der wirklich einfach besonnen und rational argumentiert, wie Heiko Maas,
zu einer, zu einer Außenposition bewegen kannst, wenn du deine Leute vernünftig positioniert hast, ja? Das heißt, du hast einen Heiko Maas, der einfach nur sagt, Freunde,
mit Sinn und Verstand an die Sache gehen, ne. Ist irgendwie unverhältnismäßig, äh wird von den,
den höchsten Gerichten äh einkassiert und so. Das ist jetzt wirklich eine dumme Idee,
haste. Das ist einfach mal rational
So, jetzt musst du aber gucken, welchen Vollextremisten schickst du irgendwie in die andere Richtung los
Da kommt sofort so ein Boßbach und so ein Uwe, die stehen da schon. So und schick sie möglichst weit irgendwo in in Richtung George Orwall, um dann als ähm Sigmar Gabriel und Angela Merkel zu sagen, ja, wir haben ja hier wieder diese beiden Extrempositionen,
Und wir sind ja aber die Mitte und deswegen preschen wir da durch, ja?
Bisschen wie mit Evolutionstheorie und.
Das verstehe ich jetzt überhaupt nicht.
Das, also es gibt ja viele Vertreter, die sagen, ja, die Evolution, das ist ja nachvollziehbar und wissenschaftlich belegt und so, aber es gibt ja auch Leute, die sind ja anderer Meinung. Ja, die so viel kreatives Design, äh,
stehen? Weißt du doch, ne?
Für die für die reine.
Wieso die Welt entstanden ist.
Nee, also.
Oder oder so Klima äh Klimawandel, entschuldigen ja genau, nicht kreativ,
kreativ grade, da gab's noch einen anderen Begriff, egal.
Und da muss man ja dann abwägen und so weiter. Dann hast du da so eine Jauch-Runde, wo dann irgendwie so Leute argumentieren mit Leute, hallo, das ist so. Irgendwie können wir können wir was anderes reden? Ja, ja, aber nein und hier und Gott und überhaupt,
Jesus und ja, also der.
Also genau, also,
du hast, du hast quasi, du hast Evolutionstheorie und dann hast du irgendwie die Bibelfundamentalisten und in der Mitte sind dann die, die sagen, ja.
Da muss man abwägen, da muss man irgendwie vermitteln und,
und er so, so kriegst du dann die Position halt irgendwie äh geschifftet.
Und am Ende hast du dann irgendwie intelligent Design äh in einigen Schulen der US.
Mit evolutionären Anwandlungen, ja.
Ja. Au, es gibt auch ein bisschen Evolution,
das ist, das macht ja auch Teil dieser Intelligenz aus.
Wir wir haben ja, wir haben auch die wir haben auch,
die Belange und äh berechtigten Forderungen der Evolution hier mit eingearbeitet.
Man muss aber musste abwägen einfach.
Genau, aber dann also letztendlich man kann das da, man kann das an diesem Vorfall sehr schön sehen und das ist ein Muster, das findet sich in der Politik einfach die ganze Zeit, ja. Du willst das, was du am Ende, das
das ist wirklich interessant. Du du machst die Politik nicht darüber, äh was du,
wie du es forderst, sondern in welchem Kontext du es forderst. Und wenn du wenn du in der wenn du in ein,
in dieses grade in so einer Palle, in in so einer Öffentlichkeitsgeleiteten Demokratie, dass auch ähm,
Deine politischen Ziele erreichen willst, dann musst du eben immer darauf achten,
in welchem Kontext du sie wie stellst und dass du möglichst,
als derjenige erscheint, der quasi so die Mitte der Diskussion hat. Das heißt, in Wirklichkeit steuerst du die,
Politik darüber, dass du den den Rahmen der Debatte lenkst,
Und dafür hast du halt, dafür brauchst du halt äh Kontrolle darüber, was die extremen Positionen sind.
Anders machst du dann nicht.
Ja. Sehr viel mehr gibt's da jetzt nicht zu zu sagen, oder?
Nee, aber also die SPD ist wirklich witzig.
Richter Vorbehalt haben sie. Das ach so, ganz kurz noch, Gabriel sagt ja, also eine der Voraussetzungen ist ja ganz klar, der Richter Vorbehalt. Der Richter Vorbehalt äh,
bei dem, bei dem Zugriff auf diese Daten, ne? Das ändert natürlich nichts daran, dass die trotzdem gesammelt werden, ja, dass sie anfallen und das ändert auch nichts daran, ich hatte es in der letzten Sendung gesagt, dass Bosbach und Uhl, wenn wir eine Fortseitenspeicherung haben, dann
dann setzen die sich ja nicht in Schaukelstuhl und sagen, ich habe, ich habe mein Leben erfüllt,
sondern dann, dann, dann äh arbeiten sie natürlich daran, die Safegards ähm,
abzubauen und halt die die Dauer auszuweiten und die die Bedingungen unter denen darauf zugegriffen werden darf äh,
auszuweiten. Also das das ist natürlich das ja und deswegen,
Deswegen argumentieren ja auch äh Aktivisten genau,
gegen diesen Dammbruch, ja, gegen die Büchse der Pandora, die damit einmal geöffnet wird und die kriegst du nicht wieder zu. Es wird einfach immer nur weiter also die die Beschränkungen,
die Beschränkungen dieser Maßnahmen durch die Grundrechte,
ähm werden immer nur weiter abgebaut, niemals.
Ja? Und deswegen genau deswegen will ja auch, wollen Gabriel und Merkel auch so in dieser in dieser Position des Besonnen, ja?
Da würde ich dann sagen, komm mal hier mit Richter Vorbehalt und so, ne, da kannst du jetzt wirklich nicht mehr,
wirklich, was wollen wir denn noch alles machen? Wie wie viele,
Grundrechtsafe Guards wollen wir denn noch alles einbauen, liebe liebe äh Grundrechtsaktivisten,
irgendwie muss ja auch mal gut sein. Und dann machst du halt im nächsten Jahr baust du die halt dann alle wieder, brauchst die alle in Ruhe ab. Ja, okay, Arschloch.
Sorry.
Ja
der äh Einwahl auch Cameron meinte ja, ne, so ja hier, also im Not
und so weiter. Also das wird ja dann hier noch unterschrieben. Also dieser Richtervorbehalt, das,
Genau, das ist das ist wirklich so die totale äh,
Das ist so die die generelle Nebelkerze einfach in dieser ganzen Debatte, ja? Also als Richter, Vorbehalt irgendetwas groß äh verhindern würde.
Also diese, die dieser Begriff in Extremes war mir übrigens auch nicht unbedingt geläufig.
Ist auch eine seltene Formulierung.
Ja, die ist dann, die hat der Redeschreiber sich dafür ausgedacht. Indextremes. Ich kann mir aber demnächst ein bisschen Index tun.
Na ja, also dieses britische, äh dieses britische Englisch für jemanden, der das ja eigentlich spricht, finde ich das ja sowieso immer ganz ganz interessant so zu hören so. In Extreme ist.
Okay, egal. Wir wir gleiten.
Driften jetzt nicht ins äh Rassistische.
Das ist nicht rassistisch. Äh Briten sind keine eigene Rasse.
Ist kein Rassismusdebatte führen, oder?
Du willst ihn ja wohl jetzt nicht doch die Ehre einer eigenen Rasse zu Teil werden lassen.
Ja, ich denke, dass sie das von sich selber schon glauben, wie.
Ja
Auch immer. Wir äh schalten um in den EU Apparat,
Das ist jetzt eher eine eine kleine Meldung. Ihr wisst schon, wenn wir das sagen, reden wir da ganz lange dadrüber, aber äh ich glaube,
gibt's nicht hier, aber ich fand's nochmal ganz interessant, um das mal so zu beleuchten. Zumal es auch mal wieder so mit so
Identitäten zu tun hat, von denen man normalerweise eigentlich relativ wenig hört, die auch irgendwie keine eigene Wikipedia-Seite haben, zumindest nicht in der deutschen.
Ähm es gibt da eine Gruppe, die heißt sehr schön Joint, Supervisory Body, JSB,
Und das ist so eine äh äh eine Gruppe innerhalb des EU ähm Gesam,
Apparat,
äh eingerichtet wurde. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie ausschließlich dafür eingerichtet wurde oder ob das jetzt die wesentliche Tätigkeit ist, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall eine Kerntätigkeit ist
die Kontrolle von.
Und
einer äh dieser Aspekte, der Kontrolle von Europol ist, auch die Einhaltung entsprechender Verträge, die Europol
Nutzt nieserisch bedient wie zum Beispiel dem sogenannten Terrorist Finance Trekking Programm T F T P was wiederum eine Vereinbarung ist,
unter anderem oder im Wesentlichen nur, weiß ich nicht genau mit den USA. Und hier geht's natürlich um den Datenaustausch. Das betrifft dann äh vor allem das Surfsystem, also das Bankensystem,
also worüber alle unsere Überweisungen,
also,
Zeiten ist es das Bankensystem, es bezeichnet auch.
Et cetera, die da zum äh Einsatz kommen, ist ein vielfältig
genutzte Abkürzung und dieses T,
FDP, Terrorist Finance Tracking Programm, das,
bis halten, Datenaustausch zwischen Europol und,
entsprechenden Behörden in den USA. Und nun soll also diese Jays,
das Ganze kontrollieren. Es gibt da eine Emily O'Reilly, die ist da die,
EU-Ombutzfrau, die in diesem JSB diesem JSB offensichtlich vorsteht oder zumindest mit diesem Bereich ähm betraut ist.
Oder das ist auch nichts brandneues. Es gibt schon seit einigen Jahren ähm schon zweitausendelf hat JSB sich äh,
beklagt, dass also die Datenschutzanforderungen der EU
hier eigentlich selten eingehalten werden oder dass es da zumindest äh Bedenken gibt bezüglich der Einhaltung von den,
U Datenschutzrichtlinien
Das hat verschiedene Anlässe gehabt sind halt vor allem so Einschränkungen, die die USA ausgehandelt haben so im Hinblick auf ja, was ist denn hier überhaupt? Und dann gibt's da nur mündliche Auskünfte, et cetera. Also diese Auskunftsregelung, die ja immer hochgehalten wird bei solchen internationalen Datenaustauschprogramm, so nach dem Motto, jetzt sind wir wieder äh,
will es nicht mit Richter Vorbehalt kommen, aber ne, also es gibt da ja Prozeduren und das ist ja alles abgesprochen und da äh hat ja die EU auch Zugriff, dass es dann sozusagen die Beruhigungspille für die Europäer, dass das ja irgendwie alles schon mit rechten Dingen
zugeht. Aber dieser JSB ist halt unzufrieden und jetzt,
ist es wohl auch so gewesen, dass äh,
was diesen TFD betrifft, da ähm,
Dokumente einsehen wollte, also bei Europol, also wir reden hier von Dokumenten der EU, ja?
Und dieser Einblick, ein bestimmtes Dokument,
wurde abgelehnt von Europol mit dem Hinweis, dass die USA da dem nicht zustimmen würden. Sprich.
Muss man sich mal vorstellen, ne? Also man hat hier sozusagen so einen Datenaustausch,
Programm, wo Daten anfallen. Es ist
die Aufgabe der EU oder zumindest die Selbstverpflichtung der EU das auch zu überprüfen. Dafür gibt es extra eine eigene Kommission, die eben dafür zuständig ist, das alles zu überprüfen, die dementsprechend natürlich auch gewissen Sicherheitszugangsregelungen äh et cetera automatisch erfüllt.
Trotz alledem reicht es sozusagen nicht aus. Die EU darf sich quasi an der Stelle nicht selbst kontrollieren.
Weil sie meinen entsprechenden Einspruch ähm,
der USA gibt das als erste Mal.
Ähm in der,
zwanzigjährigen Geschichte, die dieses also so lange gibt's dieses JSB offensichtlich schon das erste Mal, dass ihm überhaupt diesem Büro äh verwehrt worden sei, äh Dokumente einzusehen, ne? Und wohlgemerkt,
EU-Dokumente. Ja, das ist ähm,
meldet worden. Da ist berichtet worden, gibt's einen entsprechenden Artikel äh bei,
also online. Ähm ja.
Sehr interessant, weil es gibt halt eigentlich auch die die Verpflichtung für Europol, dass äh solche Daten halt äh mit Datenschutzgrundsätzen der EU ähm vereinbar sind und,
ja, das gilt eben auch für dieses Geschichte, ne,
Hinweis der USA ist wohl, dass es da irgendwie sensiblen Daten drin sind, ja, aber ähm,
Das Absurde ist, wenn es jetzt schon dieses Kontrollausschuss gibt,
Warum wird der nicht mit den entsprechenden ähm Rechten versehen,
Geheimhaltungsstufen, das trotzdem auch einzusehen. Ist ja nicht so, dass sie das sofort an die Presse bringen. Ähm,
So geht's zu und das äh habe ich jetzt für erwähnenswert gehalten, weil wir nun ja grade im Hinblick auf die Aushandlung von TTIP,
auch ähnliche Probleme immer wieder haben, beziehungsweise ähnliche ähm Probleme bei Aussendungen des Vertrages gibt,
eben zukünftig auch entsprechende Regelungen. In dem Moment, wo sie mit den USA,
oder auch anderen Ländern getroffen werden, dass
ähm auch hier entsprechende Konsequenzen zu befürchten wären.
Ja. Das ist schon ein krasses Ding, oder?
Ich fand's einfach, ja,
allerletzte Dammbruch, aber mal ein interessanter Einblick in diese ganze Geschichte,
Ja, TTIP scheint ja eh grad nicht so,
Ähm so gut anzukommen.
Wie wie schlecht kommt eigentlich an?
Wurde, das wurde ähm ja, das wurde äh hinterfragt,
gab da einen äh entsprechenden,
ähm eine Umfrage.
Durchgeführt durch die EU selber. Und ähm muss mal kurz hier nochmal den,
äh den Link hier äh öffnen, damit ich jetzt nichts falsches erzähle,
Wer hat denn das gemacht? Genau, unsere Freundin, Sizilia,
Valmström hat ja irgendwie neulich ja sogar da gewisse Eröffnungen erzielt, also man merk,
der Druck der Straße bei TTIP schon ein wenig zunimmt
ja? Das äh dich die EU-Kommission jetzt schon genötigt sieht, äh selber Dokumente zu,
veröffentlichen, ja? Also,
Dokumente im Bezug auf, was da jetzt an Vorschlägen tatsächlich auf dem Tisch liegt. Natürlich ist es nicht der komplette Verhandlungsvorgang öffentlich. Und ähm ja, jetzt gab's eine entsprechende,
Anfrage einer entsprechende, was war denn das eine,
ist Umfrage die richtige Bezeichnung dafür. Es ist von einer Online-Konsultation die Rede. Diesen Begriff habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch noch nie gehört. Ne, also man konnte sozusagen online sich zu TTIP äußern
Und es gab wohl an die hundertfünfzigtausend Eingaben,
Und äh überraschenderweise waren irgendwie siebenundneunzig,
Prozent dieser Eingaben, die dort äh online.
Konsultation äh gemacht wurden, negativ eingestellt gegenüber TTIP. Also die Fanbase hat sich da relativ zurückgehalten,
also die Westkurve hat einfach nicht geliefert und ähm ja
Klingt natürlich jetzt erstmal nach einer totalen äh fundamental Opposition, ja,
ähm allerdings ist es wohl so, dass ein Großteil dieser Rückmeldungen tatsächlich über äh Onlineplattformen übermittelt wurden
also entsprechende Bürgerrechtsorganisationen haben dann äh Onlineformulare bereit,
gestellt, äh um dort mehr oder weniger automatisiert darauf zu reagieren. Solche
Sachen haben wir ja hier auch schon mehrfach vorgestellt und äh ich halte das auch nach wie vor für den richtigen Weg, weil es ansonsten eben sehr schwierig ist, da überhaupt die Massen zu mobilisieren. Natürlich ist es ein bisschen so eine Sache, wenn jetzt quasi jeder
äh oder ein Großteil dieser E-Mails.
Automatisiert denselben Text enthält, ohne eine individuelle,
Komponente. Ja, also hätten jetzt von hundertfünfzigtausend wirklich,
äh hundert
dreißigtausend, tatsächlich äh von einzelnen Bürgern geschriebene E-Mail, dann hätte es sicherlich nochmal eine ganz andere Aussagekraft als so, aber trotz alledem ähm kann man jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass jetzt hier äh diesem Titelprojekt ein besonderer Sympathiewelle entgegen,
fliegt.
Ja, bei diesen Online Konsultationen muss ich nochmal gucken, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das per E-Mail gemacht wird
meine schon, dass sie da auch selber auf den EU-Seiten dann ähm.
Habe ich E-Mail gesagt? Dass ihr eine E-Mail schreibe, also eine E-Mail im Sinne von ein selbst verfass,
Brief oder als selbst verfassten Text den man.
Also ähm erstmal die ähm,
Also Onlinekonsultationen sind nicht unbedingt selten. Das das gibt's,
bei der äh bei der EU manchmal, zu verschiedenen äh Formen. Die haben da auch eine eigene ähm,
Plattform zu, nämlich EC Punkt Europa Punkt EU Slash Voice Slash IPM. Ähm,
und das ist äh das interactive Policy Making Prorem,
Also sie haben da werden regelmäßig so Online-Konsultationen äh ausgelobt.
Und die finden dann auch auf deren auf deren Online-Plattform statt. Also es ist nicht unbedingt so, dass ähm,
dass man da mitm mitm äh Standardtool irgendwie einfach äh,
eine E-Mailbombe hinwirft so. Aber es ist natürlich klar, dass äh oder es ist bei so einem Thema.
Ist natürlich damit zu rechnen, dass dir das Ding halt von ähm von Bürgerrechtsorganisationen.
Zugespamt wird.
Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen zugespamt, aber dass sie natürlich dazu aufrufen, daran teilzunehmen.
Ist ja klar. Und so ein Thema wie TTIP muss man natürlich auch sagen, so es gibt,
es gibt einfach kaum einen.
Also für einen Bürger der Europäischen Union kaum einen Grund dafür zu sein,
ja? Also ähm wenn das so wäre, dann ähm dann hätten ja Bürgerrechtsorganisationen, die dafür sind, auch mobilisieren können.
Ja? Und es gibt eben keine Bürgerorganisationen, die sagen, ey jo, jetzt TTIP, weil das so geil ist,
weil wir irgendwie uns uns für alle unsere Gesetze vor internationalen Schiedsgerichten verklagbar.
Na ja, müssen sich ja nicht nur Bürgerorganisationen melden, hier würden sich ja im Prinzip auch andere Gruppen.
Unternehmen melden können, ja. Haben haben sie wahrscheinlich auch, sind ja auch fünf Prozent positive dabei.
Drei, drei, drei, drei.
Drei Prozent. Ja, aber also der ähm worauf ich hinaus will ist, natürlich hast du bei solchen Bürger äh Befragungen eine ähm eine Verzerrung dadurch, dass ähm,
dass nur jene Bürger äh oder dass dass jede Bürger, die dagegen sind, überrepräsentiert sind, weil du seltener, nein, also bei so einem komplexen und so einem,
Schwierigen Thema ähm,
Du jetzt sehr wenig also, sagen wir, wenn die Bürgerrechtsorganisation nicht,
der Teilnahme an dieser Konsultation äh aufgerufen hätten, dann wäre da wahrscheinlich einfach gar nichts eingegangen.
Und das heißt, wenn du bei denjenigen wo, die du mobilisieren kannst zu dem Thema, die sind dagegen. Und das sind,
Ne, also auf den ersten Blick hast du natürlich eine Verzerrung zu denen, die dagegen sind. Andererseits sind diejenigen, die dagegen sind, auch die einzigen, die sich für das Thema interessieren. Das heißt, du kannst,
immer sagen, den größeren Teil der Bevölkerung sind egal. Aber den, den es nicht egal ist, die sind dagegen.
Also quasi, ne, dass das gleicht ja quasi diese also diese,
Zerrung auf auf eine andere, auf die auf die zweit
auf den zweiten Blick eben auch wieder aus, weil das häufig natürlich vorgeworfen wird, dass sie sagen, ja, wir haben hier konsultiert, aber da wenn immer wir konsultiert, dann
melden sich nur diejenigen da bei uns, die dagegen sind, das kann ja auch nicht sein,
weil wir sind ja die Extremisten der Mitte,
Insofern müssten ja eigentlich äh müssen ja so Ergebnisse wie sechzig Prozent Zustimmung wollen wir eigentlich immer äh einfahren und wenn wir die nicht haben, dann stimmt irgendwas nicht. Dann wurde das verzehrt.
Weil sonst würde man ja äh sonst wären wir ja irgendwie an einem Rand äh oder an irgendetwas äh beteiligt,
wo wir nicht ausgewogen auf Sicht fahren, sondern wo wir einfach mal Scheiße bauen gegen den Willen der Bevölkerung. Und das kann ja nicht sein.
Also so was zu diesen äh also das wollte ich noch so zu diesem,
diesen Online-Petitionen fahren, weil es immer, immer schwierig ist, ja, also ähm,
so eine so eine Konsultation durchzuführen, weil du dann natürlich sagst, ja,
das wird ja missbraucht. Die Konsultation wird ja vom politischen Gegner missbraucht, Tim, kannst du dir das vorstellen,
Wir fragen die Leute nach ihrer Meinung und diejenigen, die nicht unserer Meinung sind, rufen dazu auf, uns das mitzuteilen.
Ja
Also wen das interessiert hier ähm laufende Konsultationen, wenn man mal hier einen Blick auf die Webseite wirft, ist mal ganz interessant. Also man könnte jetzt hier noch ähm,
teilnehmen zum Beispiel an einer Debatte Leitlinien zur Anwendung der Sondervorschriften der Artikel hundertneunundsechzig,
einundsiebzig der GMO-Verordnung für den Olivenöl, Rindfleisch und Kulturpflanzensektor,
das Thema,
oder? Um vielleicht mal in unserem Bereich zu bleiben hier, Kommunikationsnetze, Inhalte und Technologien. Da gibt's dann äh die Konsultation öffentliche Konsultation zum Lami-Bericht,
künftige Nutzung des UHF-Rundfunkbands,
könnte man's vielleicht als Podcaster auch nochmal einbringen,
Ja, also im Prinzip ist das so eine Art.
Konsultation.
Online Lobby.
Ja ja
die wollen natürlich eigentlich da äh sinnvolle, sinnvolles Input haben, ganz gerne, ne? Also es ist nicht äh ich glaube, dass was ich äh Urheberrechtes jetzt nicht so ein Thema, was mich, was mich,
über die Maßen interessiert. Äh da war aber gerade auch was mit äh das jetzt eine EU-Konsultation zu Urheberrecht. Und ich weiß auch, dass da der äh
ähm dass da einige Leute sich natürlich dann auch darum kümmern, ja? Und das ist auch in Ordnung. Ja, also,
ich will nur sagen, dass natürlich so ein so ein Ergebnis von von siebenundneunzig Prozent gegen etwas lässt sich halt auch nicht mehr kleinreden.
Nö. Genau. Nicht mal von uns.
Nee, wir würden also diese, diese Freihandelsabkommen sind ja auch wirklich ein, ein, eine große, großer, großer Unsinn.
Aber das vereint doch irgendwie die westliche Welt und das ist doch gut für die Wirtschaft und das ist ähm ist doch schön, wenn die Menschen zusammenkommen und man keine Zölle mehr hat und wenn man irgendwie freien Handel treiben kann.
Freier Handel ist also freier Handel sollen sie von mir aus treiben, aber vielleicht äh innerhalb der gesetzlichen Rahmen, die in den Ländern existieren. Und das ist ja, also der der.
Problem ist halt, die Angleichung dieser.
Nee, nee, der Kernpunkt ist, also ein Beispiel, ja, ich bin da ja nicht so ähm,
belesen drin, deswegen bin ich jetzt sehr vorsichtig und sage äh äh take it with a green of the aber ähm der,
Atomausstieg, der von äh der deutschen Bundesregierung dann,
beschlossen wird wurde, ja, oder wird ja immer mal wieder, wir haben ja immer wieder Atomausstieg.
Vorläufige Atomausstieg.
Vorläufige Atomausstieg bis zum Wiedereinstieg. Ähm,
der hat natürlich Folgen für die Geschäftsmodelle der Atomkraftwerksbetreiber. So und der ähm,
Wenn jetzt, ich ich halte das jetzt komplett hypothetisch, weil ähm,
Wie gesagt, mit den, mit den Einzelfällen nicht so betraut bin, vertraut bin. Ähm,
Stellen wir uns mal vor, ein Atom ein ein äh Energiekonzern wie Vattenfall hätte in Deutschland ein paar Atomkraftwerke gebaut in den letzten Jahren oder Jahrzehnten, ja? Und diese die Kalkulation auf dem Profit dieser Atomkraftwerke läuft natürlich irgendwie auf.
Fall ist für dich ist aber nur ein Beispiel nicht, weil's jetzt ein äh schwedisches Unternehmen ist.
Guck mal, Tim, wenn ich einfach mal in Ruhe so äh versuchen will, vorsichtig ein Thema zu umschiffen, dann,
versuche ich das immer vorsichtig anzukündigen und sage ich nagel mich jetzt mal nicht drauf fest. Ich sage jetzt einfach was und dann kann ich mir, kann ich mir sicher sein, dass du sofort nachfragst. Deswegen muss ich jetzt schnell googeln,
Vattenfall Klage gegen Atomausstieg, weil das natürlich so ist. So, zweitausendvierzehn Vattenfall ähm,
und Eon klagen gegen äh den Atom äh gegen den ähm gegen den,
deswegen habe ich aber vorsichtig gesagt, so, aber so, dann nehme ich das jetzt doch mit rein.
Sorry. Ja.
Meine Güte, echt. Ich sag's demnächst einfach nicht mehr, weil wenn ich keine Ahnung habe und einfach vor mich hin laber und nicht vorher sage, dass ich keine Ahnung habe, dann hältst du wenigstens den Mund.
Also sorry, ich kann ja, ich kann ja nicht so viel außer nachfragen.
Beispiel. So, Vattenfall, Schwedischer Konzern,
hat in in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ein Atomkraftwerk gebaut, das Atomkraftwerk,
angeschaltet. Die haben dann Milliarden investiert und die wollen natürlich auch Milliarden mit dem Ding verdienen. So, jetzt kommt auf einmal die,
um die Ecke und sagt, ja in, in Fukushima ist so ein Ding geplatzt und bei uns ist gerade schlechte Stimmung gegen Atomkraft
also Atomausstieg. Wir verbieten die Dinger,
So und dann sagt Vattenfall natürlich, ey, wir haben aber gerade eins gebaut und das ist hier gerade, das da ist hier irgendwie die nächsten zwanzig Jahre noch in den in den roten Zahlen, alles jetzt Rechenbeispiele,
ohne ohne realistischen äh so und dann sagt Merkel, ja, tut uns leid. Wir sind jetzt verboten. Ah, habt ihr ein paar Milliarden in den Sand gesetzt.
Risiko.
Geschäftsrisiko, sorry.
Ne, besser als wenn das Ding platzt, ne. Merkel sagt natürlich gar nichts. So und dann soll aber jetzt im Rahmen dieser Freihandelsabkommen,
Soll es dein internationales Schiedsgerichte geben, vor denen oder gibt es in in verschiedenen äh Freihandelsabkommen auch schon so? Von denen Vattenfall dann sagen kann, ey Freunde, Investorenschutz, ihr könnt nicht einfach.
Irgendein Gesetz beschließen, was uns hier die Kohle wegnimmt. Die Kohle kostet.
Uns die Kohle kostet. Wir haben schließlich investiert in den guten Vertrauen, dass wir bei euch,
Atomkraftwerke betreiben, platzen lassen und den Scheiß in der Erde verbuddeln können. So und ihr verbietet uns das so, das das heißt für uns äh Verlust,
Und zwar nur, weil ihr keine vertrauenswürdigen ähm Vertragspartner seid,
genau für diesen Fall,
genau derartige Fälle sollen mit dem sollen mit den Freihandelsabkommen eben ausgeweitet und ermöglicht werden. Und das eines der Beispiele, was da eben rausgegriffen wurde,
waren diese äh waren diese Chlorhühner, ne, was ja eine Zeit lang in den Medien behandelt wurde, dass die.
Höchst erste Mal geklaut.
Kennst du nicht? Das ist geil, ey. Die ähm,
In den USA wird ja sowieso alles mit Chlor gemacht, ne? Trinkwasser, Chlor,
Alles mit mit Chlor. Ich kann, also kannst du in USA kannst du kein Glas Wasser trinken. So, auch natürlich.
Chemtrails.
Das ist die haben's Trinkwasser getan. So und dann da machen die noch nicht mal ein Geheimnis.
So und ähm unter anderem behandeln die USA eben auch,
Rahmen der Hygiene, die ähm produzierten ähm,
Hühnerkadaver mit äh mit mit Chlor,
So, das heißt, wenn du dann in den Supermarkt gehst und die irgendwie für neunundfünfzig Cent ein ausgewachsenes Huhn kaufst, was irgendwie äh, ne, da in so einer in so einer
Fabrik äh gelebt hat, bevor es dann irgendwann geschlachtet und ähm äh Federn ausgerissen und in den Häfen geschnitten und so weiter, die irgendwann geliefert wurde. Im Rahmen dieser Produktion wird das irgendwann mal kurz in Chlorbad getunkt, weil das ja auch die ganze Zeit in seiner eigenen Kacke rumgerannt ist.
So
Es könnte ja, es könnte ja sein, dass es irgendwas hat äh so und dann,
statt, dass man das vom Produktionsweg verhindert und kontrolliert und aussortiert,
macht einfach super.
Genau. So und diese ähm diese ähm diese Chlorbehandlung von Hühnern.
Bestrahlen sie das nicht einfach Radio aktiv.
Wahrscheinlich, weil Vattenfall gerade dagegen klagt. Ja, keine Ahnung.
So äh.
Gott. Ja, klar, okay.
So und in nee, warte, jetzt fällt mir gerade ein, ich glaube, die werden nicht in Chlor getunkt, sondern irgendwie durch doch. Die Amerikaner tauchen den Geflügel nach der Schlachtung in ein Chlorbad, bevor es in den Verkauf kommt. So wollen sie Erreger auf der Nackenhühnerhaut vernichten. So,
In Deutschland wird das nicht gemacht. In Europa, glaube ich, sogar nicht. So und jetzt ist, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Auf jeden Fall wurde das eben zu, dass das,
in diesem Fall jetzt die USA sagen können,
Liebe Freihandel der EU,
habt dort ein handelshemmendes errichtet, was uns daran hindert.
Hühner an eure Kunden, an eure Bürger zu verkaufen. Wir haben aber Freihandel,
Und deswegen müsst ihr jetzt eure Richtlinien abschaffen, die irgendwie den den die Grenzen für Chlor in Lebensmitteln bestimmen oder was auch immer, warum auch immer
Auf welcher beknackten Regulation ihr vermeid verbietet, verklortte Hühner an eure äh Konsumenten zu verkaufen. Diese Richtlinie muss weg im Namen des freien Handelns.
So, weil ist ein ganz klares Handelssystem, dass ihr, ihr hindert uns daran, unsere Hühner an euren Markt zu fang.
Dann seien die EU-Parlamentarier unsere.
Ja, ja, hin und her. So und dann sagen die, dann sagen die äh US-amerikanischen Hühnerproduzenten, zack, Schiedsgericht
EU-Kommission oder wer auch immer sich den Mist aufgehört, wie gesagt, ich habe ja keine Ahnung, Schiedsgericht, ihr Hahn, ihr uns entgehen äh Gewinne in Milliardenhöhe. Ähm dafür müsst ihr jetzt eine Strafe bekommen oder,
diese Richtlinie wegmachen. Das ist, das ist der.
Dann die EU-Parlamentarier von ihren Wählern im Klo getaucht wird.
Sieht nichts dagegen tun können.
Genau, das ist der, das ist der, der, der Kernkritikpunkt an diesem Freihandelsabkommen, dass quasi die äh die ähm,
Die lokale äh äh Gesetzgebung einer einer äh Handelsunion oder eines Landes zum ähm,
Zum Gegenstand einer,
supernationalen äh gerichtlichen Auseinandersetzungen werden kann,
Und das heißt, du kannst dann quasi vor diesem Schiedsgericht,
eine demokratisch erlangte Gesetzgebung klagen, weil diese ein Handelshemmnis für dich darstellt.
Und somit wird ähm also wie gesagt, ich stelle jetzt alles vereinfacht da, aber da so dass darum geht's letzten.
Wie ist unsere Art?
Von daher hast du halt ähm geht's natürlich dann auch um äh hormonell behandeltes Fleisch, Gentechnik und so weiter.
Ja
Und ähm,
Darum geht's bei diesen Freihandelsabkommen so. Das heißt, äh du müsstest jetzt, also um dafür zu sein, müsstest du quasi sagen, okay, jede ähm,
bei uns in in der EU oder in Deutschland erlangte Gesetzgebung im, insbesondere im Sinne des Verbraucherschutzes. Möge bitte dem freien Handel geopfert werden.
Und du kannst dir natürlich ungefähr vorstellen, das, was nicht passieren wird, ist, dass die EU auf einmal besseren Konsumentenschutz in den USA erklagt vor einem solchen Schiedsgericht.
Sondern weil das also diesen Weg, der ist ja bei ähm der ist ja gar nicht, den gibt's ja gar nicht, weil die EU könnte ja eh,
Ihren Scheiß da verkaufen, wenn wenn ob sie's jetzt in Chlor tunken oder nicht?
Ja? Und wenn jetzt, wenn jetzt, wenn du es als als äh als US-amerikanischer Verbraucherschützer wollen würdest
dass jedes Huhn, was auf deinem Tisch landet, in Chlor getunkt wird, ja, mal andersrum gespielt. Saß also, ich möchte, dass jedes Huhn,
Was in in den USA verkauft wird, mindestens eine Sekunde lang in Chlor gehalten wurde, damit er dich nachher noch Hühnerkacke auf der Haut klebt, wenn wir das essen. So,
Dann könnte die EU kommen und sagen, seid ihr wahnsinnig
dass er wohl ein Handelshemmnis für unsere schönen äh Biohühner mit mit,
mit garantiert genfreier Hühnerkacke am Flügel,
das möchten wir ja wohl auch verkaufen können, dann wird diese könnte dieses Verbraucherschutzgesetz eben äh vor einem solchen internationalen Schiedsrichter weggeklagt werden. Mit dem Ergebnis, dass du eigentlich,
nicht keine ähm Verbraucherschutzgesetze mehr in einem Land. Äh,
sinnvoll erheben könntest, weil du erwarten müsstest, dass ein Land, in dem dieses nicht gilt, mit dem du in einem Freihandelsabkommen steckt, die dort wieder wegklagt.
Das das löst am Ende alles der freie Markt. Da gibt's einfach dann Chlorbad to go.
Das wäre dann, das wäre dann tatsächlich der freie Markt, der jedes,
jedes Gesetz, das ihn hindert,
ähm einfach wegklagen würde,
So und am Ende wegen des Klagerisikos würdest du dann solche Gesetze gar nicht mehr machen. Das wäre also im Prinzip das Ende jeglicher Gesetzgebung, die den freien Markt in irgendeiner Form begrenzt.
Naja, also das ist schon,
Das ist schon ein starkes Stück
So, das habe ich jetzt mitgenommen, wenn ich jetzt irgendeinen Fehler drin habe, äh das ist das, was ich mitgenommen habe von dem sehr guten Vortrag von Katharina Nokuon und ihrer Kollegin von Campact auf dem einunddreißig zu drei, den wir letzte Mal schon empfohlen haben, den wir jetzt nochmal empfehlen
und ähm,
Ich hoffe, dass ich zumindest eine kurze Einführung in den Komplex äh des,
internationalen, freien Handels, der Handelshemmnisse und der Chlorhyhner,
gegeben. Hat so ein bisschen, ne? Aber.
Nee, das ist aber alles andere als witzig, lieber Tim. Ich finde das ja schön, dass du da immer noch drüber lachen kannst.
Kann da sehr drüber lachen, ja. Das ist irgendwie, ja, ich sehe, ich sehe nur gerade so ein Chlor,
irgendwie im amerikanischen Supermarkt, wo man dann zu Hause irgendwie seine äh EU Hühner nochmal,
eintunken kann, damit sie auch irgendwie konform sind und auch den richtigen Schmack.
Müsstest du in den USA echt einfach nur mal kurz unter deinen Wasserhahn.
Ja, stimmt. Das ist eigentlich eh alles okay. Weiß gar nicht, warum die sich so aufregen.
Wie gesagt, ne, das das Problem ist eben andersrum. Ähm.
Die wollen das Chlor in unserer Leitungswasser, ja.
Genau. Und äh das das Ding wurde natürlich, also es, diese ganze Chlorhhuhn
fokussierte Kampagne gegen TTIP äh ist ja auch so ein bisschen nach hinten losgegangen, wurde auch,
sich viel drüber äh lustig gemacht, aber du brauchtest halt,
auch mal was Greifbares, um das eben auch zu zeigen. So und es ist eine, ich meine,
Ich finde das schon grundsätzlich für den für die demokratische Entwicklung einer Gesellschaft sehr,
beängstigend, wenn du dich auf einmal in den Fängen der der oder rein in die, wenn du die,
Die äh Profitinteressen äh einzelne Unternehmen quasi sehr hoch,
deine äh Gesetze stellst. Und das ist eben bei diesem Atomausstieg eines der ähm,
der äh äh Risiken und das wird,
wird bei wird bei anderen Gesetzen eben auch so sein und ganz besonders schlimm ist es, wenn du dann auch noch quasi andere,
wenn du's Unternehmen dann ermöglichst, ja? Ähm quasi äh alles als Handelshemmnis wahrzunehmen und äh dir im Prinzip alles in Grund und Boden planen zu können.
Gut. Lass uns äh zu unserem letzten Thema kommen, ob wir die Sendung mal zu Ende bringen.
Ja, der der ja, du hast keine Lust mehr. Der BND.
Total Lust, aber du hast bestimmt keine Zeit mehr.
Der BND hat einen Spionagehemmnis.
Wirklich, ne? Wir Spionagehemmung.
Wir erinnern uns, wir erinnern uns an den im letzten Jahr im Juli enttarnten Doppelagenten, ja, dieser äh der hatte irgendwie zweihundert,
sechzig Dokumente irgendwie an die an die US-Amerikaner verkauf,
ja irgendwie beim BND äh bekommen hatte, weil der im Archiv gearbeitet hat, so war das ja, ne?
Ja ja einfach die Dokumente direkt an der Quelle abgezogen.
Direkt an der Quelle, aber super. Und ähm jetzt haben sie sind sie ja bei ihm eingeritten, haben ihn irgendwie seine Festplatte weggenommen und so und haben jetzt auf dieser Festplatte gefunden,
eine Liste mit Mitarbeiternamen des BND,
und gehen jetzt davon aus, dass er die natürlich auch an die Amerikaner weitergeleitet hat. So, jetzt wenn du jetzt irgendwie
bei dieser Liste oder Excel Tabelle oder was auch immer,
äh erkennst du, dass da dreieinhalbtausend Namen draufsteht?
Vom BND Mitarbeitern.
Hast du diese Liste? Nein.
Nein, wenn du willst, sitzt an dieser Stelle nicht zugeben. So, dreieinhalbtausend Mitarbeiter,
stehen, befinden sich auf dieser Liste und jetzt ist natürlich,
kannst du natürlich sagen, so was sagst du jetzt als BND, so also noch dazu, ja? Sie gehen davon aus,
dass er sie vermutlich nur an die Amerikaner weitergeleitet hat. Und wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht an andere geheim.
Aber geschnappt haben sie ihn doch, weil er eine Mail an die Russen geschickt hat.
Richtig.
Mhm.
Hat jetzt nicht die Liste gegeben. Glauben wir, glauben wir, glauben sie mir. Also, es gibt keinen Hinweis.
Alter, Alter. Sowas würden die gar nicht kaufen.
Und jetzt ist er da beim BND in der Öffentlichkeitsabteilung des WND und die Bild-Zeitung ruft bei der eine Seite, hör mal, wasn hier mit den dreieinhalbtausend Namen, die äh,
Damit ist es denn für euch so? Und dann sagt die, sagt der BND, ja äh,
Von den dreieinhalbtausend sind ja tausendfünfhundert schon gar nicht mehr bei uns tätig. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Na, na, na, na, na, na, na. Außerdem,
haben wir sechseinhalbtausend. Das heißt, von unseren sechseinhalbtausend Mitarbeitern sind nur,
zweitausend enttarnt.
Nur ein Drittel sozusagen. Ach so, einfach, na ja.
Etwas unter einem Drittel. Ja, das heißt, für unsere operative Tätigkeit ist das überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Die machen jetzt einfach alle Urlaub bezahlten und kommen nur noch die anderen dran. Wow, nicht schlecht. Wo kommt sie her, äh wo kommt diese Information jetzt her?
Das äh ist irgendwie, ich glaube, ursprünglich an die äh Bildzeitung geleakt. Ähm.
Sinne, du sprichst darauf an, dass ich es versäumt habe, dann noch einen Link in unser Pad zu gießen. Das mache ich aber natürlich jetzt auch,
gerne dreitausendfünfhundert suchen,
Leck beim Auslandsgeheims. Ach so ja.
Aber lustig, dass sie sich dazu überhaupt äußern. Und dann auch gleich so eine Qualifizierung geben. Ich meine, wenn dann hätten sie ja sagen können, mit der Arbeit der das ist einfach, kennen wir alle nicht. Nie gehört, ist alles.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das das.
Alles Decknamen und Tarnnamen und.
Das kommt ja noch dazu, da sind ja auch tatsächlich Deck und Tarnname dabei.
Ach so, na vielleicht sind das nur die äh auf YouPorn oder so.
So was in der Art. Ja, ich weiß ja, ich weiß ja nicht, wo die ähm ermitteln, aber äh der BND ist ja der Auslandsgeheimdienst, also ist äh
davon auszugehen, dass äh dass ich von diesen Leuten durchaus einige im Ausland befinden und da standen halt real Namen und
ähm Agentennamen drauf, wenn ich das so also.
Also es stand quasi so Tim Pritlaff ist als,
David Cameron in Großbritannien,
tätig.
Für uns.
Für uns, ja? Und das zweitausend Mal,
die und das ist eine Auslandsgeheimnis. Sagt der, da ist keiner. Also ne.
Es mag ja da Ähnlichkeiten geben, aber ich finde ja, David Kamerun sieht bei David nicht so gut aus.
Ja, das ist ja nur dann,
So, ne, aber okay. Und das zweitausend Mal bei einem Auslandsgeheimnis, es gibt ja irgendwie nur hundertachtzig oder zweihundert Länder auf der Welt. Ich vergesse das immer, die Gesamtanzahl der der Länder. Aber irgendwie äh
niedrig dreistellig, ja? Und das ist aber jetzt hier niedrig. Vierstellig an Personen,
Da wird jetzt nicht jeder von denen äh James Bond sein, ja? Oder also,
man dann irgendwie sich vorstellen, dass das irgendwelche Leute sind. Weiß der Geier, wo die überall arbeiten, ja, aber ist auf jeden Fall eine Menge Leute, die da jetzt enttarnt sind,
So, aber alles kein Problem.
Ja, es wird fleißig äh fleißig intarnt. Ich habe übrigens äh in dem Zusammenhang auch äh also ich komme schleppend voran mit meinem einunddreißig C drei. Ich habe dadurch nicht so die Gelegenheit gehabt, wie du dich da eine komplette Woche äh.
Das war keine komplette Woche.
Naja, die erste, was auch immer,
Genau, also man kann ja jetzt hier schon mal äh auch den den Abschluss einleiten,
nochmal so äh gegen Ende. Ich habe mir äh zumindest einen Vortrag von,
äh Erich Möchel angeschaut, seine Analyse der Datenfunkstrukturen der NSA in Wien und,
Wir schön schlüssig darlegen können, was da eigentlich wohl tatsächlich stattfindet und so. Super, super Story. Können die mir auch noch mal empfehlen, den Vortrag anzuschauen. Er hat ein paar handwerkliche Schwächen.
Ja, aber das das hatten wir, glaube ich, schon im.
Bräuchte, das haben wir schon mal erwähnt, jetzt weiß ich auch, was du meinst, also ähm da müssten definitiv,
mal die ähm verbessert werden, aber äh äh trotz alledem sehr unterhaltsam,
auch seine Art äh das zu machen und ähm,
Schön fand ich irgendwie der Hinweis, dass unter der NSA in diesem Hochhaus irgendwie eine ganze Etage von mehr oder weniger von alleine leer äh wurde, weil die Firmen da alle ausgezogen sind, weil sie einfach keinen ordentlichen Handyempfang mehr hatten,
Da wäre einfach nichts mehr, nichts mehr zu holen gewesen und deswegen wussten sie da irgendwie alle weg.
Oder wie sie auf Facebook äh war auch sehr schön, wie sie denn,
auch glaube ich auf Facebook gezeigt haben, dass sie eine neue Klimaanlage,
kriegen in einem Turm, der irgendwie erst seit zehn Jahren steht. Ja und es war auch nur oben,
wo sie halt ihre ganze Hardware stehen haben so. Sie kriegen neuen Starkstromanschluss und eine neue Klimaanlage.
Ist das nicht schön? Facebook-Smile?
Ja, da kann man, da kann man echt schön sehen, was auch so ein bisschen so äh wie soll ich sagen, also,
wenige Leute in dem Fall nahezu alle, also er hat, er hat ja seine Connections so in seiner journalistische Szene und
äh ein solcher Hinweis hat das die ganze Recherche auch ausgelöst,
man muss sich da überhaupt erstmal äh so reinknien und wenn man das dann auch tut, kann man da wirklich substantielle Ergebnisse äh herausfinden. Das ist schon
sehr unterhaltsam.
Genau, vor allem zeigt das auf, was es reicht, wenn du, wenn du, also er hat ja wirklich nur sehr, sehr wenige Hinweise gehabt
die ihr dann einfach mal untersucht hat. Und jetzt stell dir mal vor, du hast eine Liste mit zweitausend Namen,
wo du weißt, jeder einzelne von denen ist ein Agent ist BND und du kannst jetzt jede einzelne dieser Person einfach mal durchschauen, was sie so in letzter Zeit gemacht haben, bei welchen Firmen die gearbeitet haben, ähm.
Hintergründe, Familie.
So weiter, ja? Und ich meine, natürlich musst du dich dann als Geheimdienst hinstellen und sagen, ja äh,
sie weiter, hier gibt's nichts zu sehen, ist alles gar kein Problem, wir haben ja noch viereinhalbtausend andere so.
Die arbeiten zwar alle nur in der Kopieabteilung, aber es war.
Die sind unten im Archiv tätig.
Aber okay, was willst du auch anderes sagen? Ich meine, du kannst natürlich als Geheimdienst niemals wirklich öffentlich zugeben, dass dass du grade irgendwie massives Problem hast.
Und vor allem, eventuell ist es tatsächlich ein kein Problem, weil äh die Annahme inzwischen jetzt nicht irgendwie aus der Welt wäre, dass die NSA wahrscheinlich eine sehr viel längere Liste als nur dreieinhalbtausend und auch eine sehr viel aktuellere Liste äh als von vor ein paar Jahren äh von der
äh von der äh von den Mitarbeitern des BND hat. So, wer jetzt, also ich meine, also jetzt inzwischen keine äh keine Vermutung mehr, die besonders ähm,
unwahrscheinlich wäre.
Wie auch immer, wir müssen jetzt mal ein Ende finden. Die Zeit äh,
nagt hier. Hatten wir uns nicht irgendwann mal vorgenommen irgendwie unter einer Stunde zu bleiben? Naja, wir sind unter zwei Stunden geblieben.
Noch was zu sagen irgendwie.
Ja, es es gibt wie immer bei den abschließenden Worten den Dank an den Dennis.
Mhm. Oh, wie immer. Gut. Dank Dennis, wir danken äh allen Zuhörern. Wir danken allen zugeschalteten äh Podcasthörern und äh bis bald. Nächste Woche geht's weiter. Tschau, tschau. Tschüss.
Tschau, tschau.